JOINED BY.
SENATOR MIKE MCGUIRE THE CHAIR
OF THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE --
AND THIS IS A JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING BETWEEN
THE TWO TO COMMITTEES --
ABOUT ENTITLED ADDRESSING
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING SHORTAGE
HOW CAN WE CREATE ENVIRONMENTS
TO FACILITATE HOUSING --
DEVELOPMENT ODD FOR START IF I
COULD ASK EVERYONE TO TURN OFF
YOUR CELL PHONE AND IF YOU HAVE
CONVERSATIONS TO ENGAGE IN
PLEASE STEP OUTSIDE.
SO THAT WE CAN HEAR THE
TESTIMONY --
THE HEARING WILL CONSIST OF
THREE PANELS --
TO GO OVER --
FIRST --
CURRENT LOCAL ZONING AND
PLANNING PROCESS SEES --
THEN THE STATE PLANNING REQUIRE
ME TO FACILITATE THE CREATION OF
HOUSING.
AFTER EACH PANEL MEMBERS WHO
WILL BE I THINK GRADUALLY
JOINING US --
WILL -- BE
ABLE TO ASK QUESTIONS IN THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WILL BE
ABLE TO GET PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE END.
OF PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE TWO
MINUTES PER SPEAKER --
SO -- WHAT
WE DECIDED TO HAVE THIS HEARING
AS WE --
START OFF OUR LEGISLATIVE --
YEAR --
WE'RE AT THE NOW THE AND THE
BILL INTRODUCTIONS AND THERE ARE
A LOT OF HOUSING BILLS HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED.
ON AND YOU KNOW WE ARE --
I THINK IT'S NOT A SURPRISE TO
ANYONE THAT --
IN CALIFORNIA WE FACE A IT'S
BEEN CALLED A HOUSING --
SHORTAGE ALL OF THESE THINGS ON
OUR TRUE WHATEVER WE WANT TO
CALL IT --
AND WE USE A LOT OF TACTICAL --
TERMS LIKE ZONING AND SEQUEL --
AND CONDITIONAL USE AND BELOW
MARKET RATE HOUSING AND SO ON
AND SO FORTH --
I ALWAYS LIKE TO TRY --
TO LOOK AT THIS ISSUE --
NOT IN TERMS OF THE
TECHNICALITIES --
BUT IN TERMS OF THE HUMAN
IMPACTS OF THE HOUSING CHOICES
THAT WE MADE IN CALIFORNIA --
OVER DECADES WE HAVE ACCUMULATED
A THREE POINT FIVE MILLION HOME
HOUSING DEFICIT.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
IS APPROX THAT OF THE OTHER
FORTY NINE STATES ARE COMBINED --
WE ARE TOLD BY OUR LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S THAT WE ARE ARE PRETTY
CONSISTENTLY --
PRODUCING EITHER SLIGHTLY LESS
THAN HALF FOR SLIGHTLY MORE THAN
HALF OF THE HOUSING THAT WE NEED
TO PRODUCE IN CALIFORNIA JUST TO
KEEP UP WITH GROWTH --
AND THE IMPACTS ARE --
ARE ARE TRAGIC --
5% SCHOOL CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
OR HOMELESS --
HOUSING SHORTAGE IS DRIVING
PEOPLE INTO HOMELESSNESS IT IS --
PERHAPS THE PRIMARY DRIVER OF
POVERTY --
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA LARA
IS PUSHING FAMILIES OUT OF
COMMUNITIES CREATING SUPER
COMMUTERS WHO DRIVE AN HOUR AND
A HALF TWO HOURS EACH WAY TO
WORK.
UNDERMINING OUR CLIMATE GOALS
AND CLOGGING OUR FREEWAYS --
AND IT THIS IS --
YOU KNOW WE WE SEE ECONOMIC
DAMAGE IN SAN FRANCISCO THERE
ARE RESTAURANTS THAT ARE CLOSING
DOWN.
NOT FOR LACK OF BUSINESS BUT
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T HOW STATEWIDE
USED TO BE VIEWED AS JUST A FEW --
CITIES HERE IN THERE THAT WERE
REALLY HAVING MAJOR PROBLEMS
IT'S A PROBLEM AND THE BOOK OF
CALIFORNIA --
AND WE NEED --
TO REALLY TAKE BOLD STEPS --
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH
HOUSING FOR EVERYONE WHO NEEDS A
THAT WE'RE BUILDING AT ALL
INCOME LEVELS AND AND AND IN MY
VIEW THAT WE'RE PROTECTING --
TENANTS FROM EVICTION.
SO WITH THAT I WILL DIE TURNED
OVER TO CENTER MCGUIRE FOR
OPENING REMARKS AND THEN WE'LL
GET TO OUR FIRST PANEL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER WINNER
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
YOURSELF IN YOUR TEAM UP FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS CRITICAL
HEARING --
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO BE PARTNER
WITH YOU SIR.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE IN A SERIES OF
HEARINGS UP AND DOWN CALIFORNIA.
THE FIRST --
IT WOULD WERE WE WERE DISCUSSING
HOW HOW TO ADDRESS IT THROUGH
FURTHER STATE FINANCIAL
INVESTMENTS PARTICULAR WHEN IT
COMES TO WORK FORCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
OUR SECOND HEARING FOCUS ON LAND
USE CHANGES THAT ARE NEEDED TO
ENABLE ADDITIONAL FOUR DOUBLE
AND MARKET RATE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION.
IN HERE TODAY FOCUS ON ZONING
AND PLANNING REQUIREMENTS.
THIS IS WHAT WE KNOW.
AFTER THE SERIES OF MEETINGS IN
HEARINGS WE POSTED OVER THE LAST
MANY MONTHS CALIFORNIA IS FACED
WITH A SERIES OF COMPLEX
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BUILD OUT OF HOUSING.
HIGHLAND PRICES.
THE LACK OF HOUSING SOCCER
ASSOCIATED WITH THE MAN.
THE LACK OF ONGOING SUSTAINABLE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING REVENUE.
REGULATORY HURDLES HI CASA SO
SHE WOULD PERMITTING AND YES
OWNING AN INABILITY IN SOME
JURISDICTIONS THE BILL STRATEGIC
INFILL HOUSE.
IT'S GONNA TAKE TIME TO BE ABLE
TO BUILD OUR WAY OUT OF THE
SIGNIFICANT DEFICIT THAT'S
FACING US.
AND WE MUST HAVE A LASER FOCUS
ON THE BUILD OUT OF WORK FORCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS IN BIG
CITIES AND SMALL.
THIS IS WHY I FOCUS ON THE ISSUE
OF AFFORDABLE.
THE TRUE CRISIS EXISTS WITH THE
WORKING POOR AND MIDDLE CLASS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE SHORT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION AFFORDABLE UNITS.
ACROSS THE STATE WITHIN THOSE
THREE AFFORDABLE RINA CATEGORIES.
EVERY CITY IN COUNTY IN THE
GOLDEN STATE MUST DO THEIR PART.
AND CANDIDLY THE STRATEGY OF NO
NO LONGER WORKS.
IT'S TIME TO STEP UP.
IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
HELP YOU STAND STRONG.
THAT'S WHY THE STATE NEEDS TO
DEVELOP A PERMANENT REVENUE
SOURCE TO HELP SUBSIDIZE THE
COST OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
IN.
I DO BELIEVE THAT IT'S GONNA
WE'RE GONNA NEED MEASURES THAT
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE UNIQUE
DIFFERENCES OF JURISDICTIONS
BECAUSE THEY BLANK.
BLANK IT ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH SIMPLY DOES NOT WORK
WITH THAT AGAIN CENTER WIENER
I'M REALLY GRATEFUL TO BE
WORKING WITH YOU SIR.
AN ALTERNATE OVER TO FOR THE
FIRST.
THANK YOU CENTER MCGUIRE I'M
SORRY FIRST PANEL IS ENTITLED
THE IMPACTS ON HOUSING OF ZONING
AND THE APPROVAL PROCESS.
WE HAVE FOUR WITNESSES --
DAN RENSSELAER THE SENIOR POLICY
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP CORPORATION.
I DAVID GARCIA WHO IS A PUBLIC
POLICY DIRECTOR AT THE UC
BERKELEY --
TURNER CENTER --
TO MAKE A MáS THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF HAMILTON
FAMILIES --
AND CAROLINE COLEMAN THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES --
SO THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US
HERE TODAY --
WITH --
ASSET IF YOU COULD KEEP YOUR
PRESENTATION TO ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES OR SO --
THAT WOULD BE A GREAT --
SO -- WE
WILL GO IN THE ORDER I JUST
STATED SO MISTER RENTS ARE YOU
CAN START.
GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING US --
AND HAVING ME --
YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY WITH THIS
MY US GREAT.
ON PAPER TO JUST A LITTLE BIT
CLOSER TO THE STANDARDS ARE NOW.
RATES -- SO.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HAVING ME MY
NAME IS DAN RENSSELAER AND I'M A
SENIOR POLICY ANALYST AT THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP.
WE WERE CREATED THIRTY YEARS AGO
BY THE STATE ALTHOUGH WE DO NOT
RECEIVE ANY ONGOING STATE
FUNDING.
OUR STAFF HAS HELPED PUBLIC AND
NONPROFIT HOUSING AGENCIES
LEVERAGE EIGHTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN FINANCING AND CREATE
SEVENTY THOUSAND FOUR WILL HOMES
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
WE ALSO PROVIDE RESEARCH AND
LEADERSHIP ON HOUSING POLICY
ISSUES.
SO MANY OF YOU ARE PROBABLY
FAMILIAR WITH THE WAY THAT
REDLINING RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
AND OTHER EXPLICITLY RACIST
POLICIES IN THE POST WAR ERA
CREATED AN ENTRENCHED.
RACIALLY SEGREGATED GEOGRAPHY OF
OPPORTUNITY IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WHERE YOUR RACE DETERMINE THE
NEIGHBORHOOD WHERE YOU LIVED THE
FINANCIAL SERVICES AVAILABLE TO
YOU?
AND THE RESOURCES THE HAVE
ACCESS TO IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD.
IN PART OF THE LEGACY OF THESE
POLICIES HAS BEEN AN UNEVEN
GEOGRAPHY OF OPPORTUNITY WITHIN
METROPOLITAN AREAS WHERE YOUR
CHILDHOOD NEIGHBORHOOD PLAYS A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN DETERMINING
YOUR LONG TERM ECONOMIC
PROSPECTS.
IN EDUCATIONAL SUCCESS EVEN YOUR
PHYSICAL MENTAL HEALTH --
IN THIS MAP OF LOS ANGELES AND
ORANGE COUNTY CHILDREN WHO LIVED
IN AREAS SEATED BLUE TENDED TO
MOVE UP THE ECONOMIC LADDER AS
ADULTS BUT THOSE WHO GREW UP IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD SEATED READ DID
NOT.
WE ALSO KNOW FROM RESEARCH THAT
WE HAVE DONE IN THE BAY AREA AT
THAT RACE CONTINUES TO PLAY A
LARGER ROLE THAN INCOME IN
DETERMINING WHO HAS ACCESS TO
HIGH RESOURCE HIGH OPPORTUNITY
NEIGHBORHOODS.
SO LOW INCOME WHITE FAMILIES
ENJOY DECENT ACCESS TO THESE
TYPES OF NEIGHBORHOODS AS THEY
SHOULD --
BUT LOW INCOME BLACK AND LET
NEXT DO NOT --
EVEN HIGHER --
TO MODERATE TO HIGHER INCOME
BLACK FAMILIES JUST ARE
TYPICALLY LIVE IN HIGHER POVERTY
LOW RESOURCE NEIGHBORHOODS
WEATHER PROSPECTS SIMPLY JUST
AREN'T AS GOOD.
WE ALSO KNOW FROM SURVEY DATA
THAT THESE PATTERNS OF
SEGREGATION DO NOT REFLECT THE
ACTUAL LOCATION PREFERENCES OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR --
DAY TYPICALLY END UP LIVING IN
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE MORE
SEGREGATED THAN WHERE THEY SAY
THEY WOULD LIKE TO LIVE IN WHERE
THEY ACTUALLY SEARCH FOR HOUSING.
IN WHAT WE AT THE CALIFORNIA
HAVING HOUSING PARTNERSHIP HAVE
OBSERVED THROUGH A STUDY WITH
THE URBAN DISPLACEMENT PROJECT
AT UC BERKELEY IS THAT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AS RENTAL HOUSING
PRICES HAVE SKYROCKETED.
THIS OLD GEOGRAPHY OF
SEGREGATION IN THE BAY AREA HAS --
SORT OF RESTRUCTURED AND
RESHUFFLE BUT NOT BROKEN DOWN ON
CENSUS DATA SHOWS THAT
CONCENTRATED INCREASES INDIAN
DECREASES AND LOW INCOME PEOPLE
OF COLOR HAPPENED IN CERTAIN
NEIGHBORHOODS FALL COMPLETELY BY
PASSING PREDOMINANTLY WHITE.
IN HIGHER INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS
SO THIS PARTICULAR MAP SHOWS.
INCREASES AND DECREASES AND LOW
INCOME BLACK HOUSEHOLDS PURPLE
IS A DECREASE GREEN AS AN
INCREASE.
WE ALSO FOUND THAT AT THE
NEIGHBORHOOD LEVEL LOW INCOME
PEOPLE OF COLOR WERE MORE
VULNERABLE TO THE EFFECTS OF
RENT INCREASES AND WERE
DISPLACED AT HIGHER RATES.
SO IN THE FIFTEEN YEAR PERIOD
FROM TWO THOUSAND TO TWENTY
FIFTEEN A 30% RISE IN RENTS AT
THE NEIGHBORHOOD LEVEL WAS
ASSOCIATED WITH A 20% DROP IN
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS OF COLOR.
BUT NO CHANGE IN THE NUMBER OF
LONGER MIGHT HOUSEHOLDS WHO
APPEAR TO BE MUCH MORE RESILIENT
TO THE VAGARIES OF THE RENTAL
MARKET.
DURING THE SAME PERIOD THE
LANDSCAPE OF HIGH POVERTY
RACIALLY SEGREGATED
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE REGION ALSO
SHIFTED INTO NEW PARTS OF THE
REGION.
BUT THESE ARE NEIGHBORHOODS WERE
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT LOW
INCOME FAMILIES TYPICALLY FACE
GREATER CHALLENGES --
MOVING UP THE ECONOMIC LADDER
GETTING A CALL.
IN IN THESE MAPS AREAS THAT
NEWLY MET THIS DEFINITION IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN ARE SHOWN AND
CROSS HATCH --
AREAS THAT WERE ALREADY POOR IN
SEGREGATED IN TWO THOUSAND ARE
SHOWN IN ORANGE.
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT MOST OF
THE MAP IS WHITE.
MOST NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE BAY
AREA ARE NOT CHARACTERIZED BY A
RACIAL SEGREGATION AND POVERTY
IT'S A PRETTY RARE PHENOMENON.
BUT WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT ONCE
THIS PLACE LOW INCOME FAMILIES
OF COLOR OFTEN FOUND THEMSELVES
MOVING TO THESE NEWLY POOR
ANNUALLY SEGREGATED
NEIGHBORHOODS.
OFTEN ON THE PERIPHERY OF THE
REGION.
AND ALSO THAT LOW INCOME PEOPLE
OF COLOR IN PARTICULAR BLACK AND
LET NEXT HOUSEHOLDS WERE MUCH
MORE LIKELY TO LIVE IN THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS BEEN LOW INCOME MY
HOUSEHOLD SO.
IF YOU'RE BLACK AND LOW INCOME
IN THE BAY AREA YOUR MOM MORE
THAN LIKELY TO LIVE IN A HIGH
NEIGHBORHOOD IF YOU'RE LOW
INCOME AND WHY.
LESS THAN 10% LIKELIHOOD OF
LIVING IN ONE OF THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS.
WE ALSO ASKED WHO GETS TO LIVE
IN HIGH RESOURCE HI OPPORTUNITY
NEIGHBORHOODS WHOSE
CHARACTERISTICS ARE MORE
STRONGLY PREDICTIVE OF UPWARD
MOBILITY IN GOOD EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES FOR LOW INCOME CHILDREN.
USER AREAS THAT ARE SHOWN IN THE
DARKER GREEN COLOR IN THE THREE
COUNTY LEVEL MAPS THE BAY AREA.
AND AGAIN THE RESULTS FALL
LARGELY FALLEN RACIAL LINES LOW
INCOME WHITE HOUSEHOLDS ARE
SEVEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO LIVE
IN HIGH RESOURCE NEIGHBORHOODS
THAN EVEN MODERATE TO HIGH
INCOME BLACK HOUSEHOLDS SIMILAR
DISPARITIES BETWEEN WHITE LATIN
X. HOUSEHOLDS IN THE BAY AREA.
SO THESE RESULTS ARE WHICH WE
WOULD PROBABLY EXPECT TO SEE IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE OR PART
OF THE LEGACY OF MORE EXPLICITLY
RACIST POST WAR --
HOUSING AND LAND USE PLANNING
POLICIES THAT LIVE ON TODAY
JUSTIN RECONFIGURED FORMS --
THEIR DEEP RACIAL DISPARITIES
THAT PROBABLY WON'T GET FIXED
WITHOUT DELIBERATE STATE AND
LOCAL.
POLICIES IN INVESTMENTS WHICH
AFFIRMATIVELY HELP LOW INCOME
PEOPLE OF COLOR LIVE IN ANY
NEIGHBORHOOD.
THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO LIVE IN
THAT THEY DESIRE DISPARITIES IN
RESOURCES ACROSS NEIGHBORHOODS.
THERE ARE THREE WAYS THAT --
AT A HIGH LEVEL THE STATE CAN
TRY TO BRING THIS INTO ACTION
FIRST CREATE NEW AFFORDABLE
HOMES AND HIGH OPPORTUNITY HIGH
RESOURCE NEIGHBORHOODS.
WHETHER SUBSIDIZED OR THROUGH AN
INCLUSIONARY POLICY.
SECOND STABILIZE HOUSING PRICES
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
PROTECTING INS AND NEIGHBORHOODS
WERE RENTS ARE RISING THE
FASTEST WHICH FOR A LOT OF
PLACES BUT NOT EVERYWHERE.
IN THIRD DIRECT INVESTMENT --
IN SUPPORT CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN HIGH POVERTY
RACIALLY SEGREGATED
NEIGHBORHOODS INCLUDING THOSE
EXPERIENCING THESE DYNAMICS FOR
THE VERY FIRST TIME.
THAT'S ALL I'VE GOT --
I COMPOSED FOR QUESTIONS ARE
PASSED ON TO THE NEXT BAKER.
WHAT DO QUESTIONS AT THE END OF
THE TUNNEL OKAY?
TAKE A MOMENT TO PULL OF MYSELF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
ME HERE THIS AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS DAVID GARCIA AND THE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE TURNER CENTER
FOR HOUSING INNOVATION AT UC
BERKELEY --
FOR THOSE WHO ARE UNFAMILIAR
WITH THE WORK OF THE TURNER
CENTER WE ARE A HOUSING RESEARCH
AND POLICY ORGANIZATION AT THE
BERKLEE COLLEGE OF OUR MENTAL
DESIGN AS WELL AS THE HOUSE.
SCHOOL OF BUSINESS.
AND SO I'VE BEEN ASKED HERE THIS
AFTERNOON TO PRESENT SOME OF THE
FINDINGS OF OUR RECENT
CALIFORNIA LAND YOU SURVEY.
A SPECIFICALLY REGARDING ZONING
ISSUES AND OTHER BARRIERS TO
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND SO --
THE TURNER CENTER LAND USE
SURVEY WAS A MULTI YEAR EFFORTS
TO CATALOG THE LANDSCAPE.
OF ZONING PRACTICES AND LAND USE
PRACTICES ACROSS THE STATE BY
SURVEYING LOCAL PLANNING
DEPARTMENTS ON THE RESULTS FROM
THE SURVEY CAN GIVE US UNIQUE
INSIGHTS INTO THE VARIOUS.
ZONING ORDINANCES FOR THE
HOUSING PROGRAMS APPROVAL
PROCESS SEES AND IT'S AN
OBJECTION POLICIES THAT IS EXIST
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND CAN HELP US IDENTIFY POLICY
BARRIERS THAT HINDER THE
PRODUCTION OF NEW HOUSING.
AND SO OUR WORK BILLS OFF
PREVIOUS SURVEYS THAT EXAMINE
SIMILAR TOPICS SUCH AS THE
BROOKINGS RESIDENTIAL LAND USE
REGULATIONS SURVEY AND THE
WHARTON.
LAND USE SURVEY.
WE ALSO WORKED WITH H. C. D. TO
IDENTIFY AND PRIORITIZE AREAS
THAT WOULD BE THE MOST USEFUL
AND LINING TO UNDERSTANDING.
LAND USE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND OUR SURVEY WAS ADMINISTERED
ONLINE.
AND WE RECEIVED RESPONSES
BETWEEN AUGUST TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND OCTOBER.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS YOU CAN SEE
HERE TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE
JURISDICTIONS TO PARTNER SURVEY
ACCOUNTING FOR ABOUT 70% OF THE
STATE'S OVERALL POPULATION.
AND ONE OF THE MOST INTERESTING
FINDINGS REGARDING ZONING FROM
OUR SERVER WAS JUST THE SHEER
AMOUNT OF LAND.
THAT ALLOWS FOR SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES TO BE BUILT.
SO AS YOU CAN SEE HERE OVER 70%
OF ZONE LAND IN CALIFORNIA
ACCORDING TO OUR SURVEY.
ALLOWS FOR SINGLE FAMILY HOME
BUILDING WHEREAS ALL OF THE LAND
IS OWNED FOR MULTI FAMILY.
BUILDINGS --
COMPRISES LESS THAN A QUARTER
LANDON AND THIS IS NOT JUST --
CHARACTERISTIC OF SMALLER
SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES WE ACTUALLY
FOUND THAT ARE LARGER CITIES
SUCH AS LOS ANGELES SAN JOSE SAN
DIEGO THE REPORTED TO US IN IN
OUR SURVEY THAT.
UNDER A QUARTER OF THEIR LANDS
ON FOR MULTI FAMILY AS WELL.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT --
THE TIME IT TAKES TO APPROVE A
PROJECT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
FACTOR IN WHETHER NOT HOUSING
GETS BUILT SO TO THAT END WE
ALSO ASKED A QUESTION --
UP TO THE PLANNERS ABOUT HOW
LONG IT ACTUALLY TAKES HIM TO
PROVE HOUSING AND BY LARGE WE
SEE THAT NGUYEN PROJECTS AT HERE
TO EXISTING REGULATIONS AS
DETERMINED BY GENERAL PLAN.
OR OR ZONING CITIES MOSTLY CAN
APPROVE PROJECTS WITHIN SIX
MONTHS HOWEVER AS PROJECTS
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL LAYERS OF
APPROVAL OR REQUEST --
ZONING VARIANCES --
AND OR IF THEY REQUIRE
ENVIRONMENT IMPACT PORT PERCY
CLUB.
THE NUMBER OF CITIES THAT
REPORTED --
THEIR ABILITY TO APPROVE
PROJECTS WITHIN SIX MONTHS
ACTUALLY FALLS PRETTY LOW.
AND WE KNOW THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE MOST PROJECTS FOR MANY
PROJECTS TO REQUIRE HE A OURS
AND MANY OTHER PROJECTS ALSO
ROUTINELY WILL REQUEST VARIANCES.
FOR FOR FOR MANY MANY PURPOSES
TO GET A PROJECT FEASIBILITY.
AND SO TO THAT LAST POINT WE
ALSO ASKED PLANNERS ABOUT THE
TYPES OF VARIANCES IN EXCEPTIONS
THAT THEY SEE.
AND AS ILLUSTRATED HERE YOU CAN
SEE THAT THINGS LIKESET BACKS
WANT COVERAGE --
FAIRLY COMMON FOR BOTH SINGLE
FAMILY AND MULTI FAMILY PROJECTS --
WE CAN ALSO SEE THAT'S MULTI
FAMILY PROJECTS --
CAN COMMONLY REQUEST THINGS --
VARIANCES FOR PARKING HEIGHTS --
RESTRICTIONS AND FOR DENSITY AS
WELL.
IN ADDITION TO THEIR EXISTING
ZONING WE ASK CITIES WHETHER OR
NOT THEIR ZONING REGULATIONS
HAVE BECOME MORE OR LESS
RESTRICTIVE IN THE PAST FIVE
YEARS.
AND ENCOURAGINGLY.
OVER 50% SAY THAT TO THERE'S
ONLY HAS BECOME LESS RESTRICTIVE
AND ANECDOTALLY THIS SEEMS RIGHT
BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE ARE MANY
CITIES THAT ARE ACTING
PRACTICALLY TO TRY.
AND REDUCE BARRIERS --
TO HOME --
CONSTRUCTION IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
ON THE OTHER HAND WE ALSO HAVE
OVER 40% OF COMMUNITIES IS SAY
THAT NOTHING HAS CHANGED IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS AND A HANDFUL
COMMUNITIES THAT ACTUALLY SAY
THAT THEIR ZONING REGULATIONS
HAVE BECOME MORE RESTRICTIVE.
IN ADDITION.
TO EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES THAT CITIES EMPLOY WE
ASK PLANNERS AS WELL WHAT DID
THEY THINK WERE THE MOST SEVERE
CONSTRAINTS TO HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS.
AND THE RESULTS WERE A BIT
SURPRISING ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
THE CONVERSATION AROUND HOUSING
TENDS TO REVOLVE AROUND THINGS
LIKE SELLING SEQUEL A FEES
THINGS LIKE THAT.
BUT ACCORDING TO THE PLANNERS
WHO RESPONDED TO OUR SURVEY
THOSE ISSUES WERE ACTUALLY RANG
TO TOWARDS THE BOTTOM OR AS
OTHER THINGS SUCH AS LAND SUPPLY
PERSONAL CONFIGURATION
LANDOWNERSHIP --
WERE IDENTIFIED AS THE AS THE
MOST SEVERE CONSTRAINTS.
AND SO --
I'M GONNA LEAVE IT THERE WE HAVE
A LOT OF OTHER INFORMATION WITH
REGARDS TO FROM HOUSING POLICIES.
AND PROTECTIONS --
AND SO ON SO I IN OUR WORK TO
VISIT THE PROJECT WEBSITE WHICH
IS CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU SAID ORG.
WHERE YOU CAN DOWNLOAD ARE
DESCRIPTIVE REPORTS AND YOU CAN
ACTUALLY DOWNLOAD THE DATA
YOURSELF SO --
WITH THAT LIKE TO THINK MEGAN
FOR HAVING THE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS MOSS.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME TODAY.
MY NAME IS TO MICAH MáS AND I'M
THE CEO OF HAMILTON FAMILIES.
AYE HAMILTON FAMILIES AS A
THIRTY FOUR YEAR OLD
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS --
TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
TRANSITIONAL AND PERMANENT
HOUSING SOLUTIONS FOR FAMILIES
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
SO I'D LIKE TO ACTUALLY TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE PEOPLE --
YOU KNOW WHAT DOES THIS CRISIS
LOOK LIKE FOR THE PEOPLE OF OUR
OF OUR STATE --
WE STAND TO LOSE THE VERY
COMMUNITIES THAT ACTUALLY HELP
TO BUILD THIS GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IF WE STAND ON THE SIDELINES AND
NOT TAKE THIS HOUSING CRISIS
SERIOUSLY.
WITH RAPID JOB GROWTH.
GROWING INCOME INEQUALITY AND
THE SEVERE UNDER PRODUCTION THAT
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE TALKED ABOUT --
IN HOUSING ACROSS ALL ECONOMIC
LEVELS IT THREATENS THE VERY
DIVERSITY OF THIS REGION.
AND WE MUST ACT NOW.
AND IT TAKES NOT ONLY ACTION BUT
THE POLITICAL WILL TO TAKE
ACTION.
YOU KNOW I OFTEN AM IN
CONVERSATION WITH FOLKS ABOUT
HOUSING AND WE TALK ABOUT IT
IT'S A DEBATE ABOUT OUR
PROGRESSIVE VALUES.
AROUND INCLUSION IN THE
CELEBRATION OF THAT DIVERSITY
THAT CALIFORNIA PRIDES ITSELF ON
BUT IF WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY
WILLING TO ACT IN SUPPORT
HOUSING POLICIES THAT FACILITATE
THAT VERY INCLUSION.
AND ENSURE THAT WE HAVE RACIALLY
AND ECONOMICALLY INTEGRATED
COMMUNITIES.
THAT OFFER PROSPERITY FOR ALL
THEN WE ARE COLLECTIVELY NOT
DOING OUR JOBS.
I'M INVOLUNTARY DISPLACEMENT IS
HAPPENING EVERYWHERE IN OUR
STATE.
AND IT'S IT'S SPECIALLY
HAPPENING FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE OUTLINED IN
THEIR PRESENTATIONS.
I WAS A MEMBER OF THE TECHNICAL
COMMITTEE THAT WORKED ON CASA.
AND WE PAID A LOT OF ATTENTION
AROUND WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO FOR
THE TENANTS WHO ARE BEING WHO
ARE ATRISK OF DISPLACEMENT
RIGHT NOW.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO FOR FOLKS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND HOW DO WE HOUSE
THE BAY AREA OF THE FUTURE?
SO THE CASA QUE ELEMENTS THAT WE
DESCRIBED AROUND OUR TENANT
PROTECTIONS --
ARE JUST TO START AND HOW WE
THINK THE STATE NEEDS TO TAKE
LEADERSHIP AROUND MAKING SURE
THAT EXISTING TENANTS AND
RESIDENTS ARE ABLE TO STAY IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
ARE JUST BECAUSE OF DICTION
POLICY.
A BASE LINE POLICY THAT MANY
JURISDICTIONS HAVE ALREADY
ADOPTED THAT WE THINK WILL ALLOW
FOR THOSE PROTECTIONS FOR
TENANTS TO BE ABLE TO STAY IN
THEIR HOMES.
WE TALK ABOUT RENT CAPS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN RENTS GO UP 20% IN
A IN A IN A ONE BEDROOM UNIT IN
THAT PERSON IS DISPLACED.
WE CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT THAT.
WE ALSO TALK ABOUT RENT
ASSISTANCE AND ACCESS TO LEGAL
COUNSEL IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
WHEN IT WHEN A PERSON IS
EXPERIENCING AN EVICTION PROCESS
TO HAVE ACCESS TO COUNSEL
ACTUALLY PREVENTS THEM FROM
COMING INTO MY PROGRAM WITH THE
VISIONS ON THE RECORDS.
SO THESE ARE THE KINDS OF
SOLUTIONS THAT WE BELIEVE
DECISION MATERS DECISION MAKERS
LIKE YOURSELVES CAN TAKE AN OWN
AND WE KNOW THE PRODUCTION IS
IMPORTANT WE HAVE GOT TO BUILD
MORE HOUSING.
BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF WRAPPING THAT
PRODUCTION GOALS AROUND TEN AND
PROTECTIONS AND PRESERVATION TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
STAY IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
YOU KNOW LAND USES VERY LOCAL
AND IT'S PERSONAL FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
BUT WE CANNOT PROMOTE THE STATUS
QUO I THINK SENATOR YOU TALKED
ABOUT HOW NO WAS NO LONGER PART
OF THE SOLUTION WE MUST BE ABLE
TO BE COURAGEOUS AND SAY YES TO
HOUSING.
EVERYONE IN THIS STATE DOES
DESERVE AFFORDABLE PLACE THAT
THEY CAN LIVE.
WE HAVE TO EMBRACE INCLUSIONARY
ZONING THAT CREATES
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HOUSING TO BE
BUILT NOT ONLY TO ACCOMMODATE
THE THE FAILURE OF GROWTH.
WELL THE FAILURE OF HOUSING
PRODUCTION IN OUR COMMUNITIES
BUT WE MUST ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR EXISTING RESIDENTS ARE ABLE
TO STAY HOUSE.
THE URGENCY IS REALLY NOW.
EVERY DAY WHEN I WORK WITH
FAMILIES IN OUR PROGRAMS
FAMILIES THAT TAKE THEIR KIDS TO
SCHOOL EVERY DAY.
FAMILIES THAT GO TO WORK EVERY
DAY AND THEN RETURN HOME TO MY
SHELTER BECAUSE THEY ARE STILL
HOMELESS IN THE BAY AREA.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
CHANGE.
THESE FAMILIES ARE INCREDIBLY
RESILIENT.
AND THEY'RE ADAPTABLE AND I
ENCOURAGE US ALL AS LEADERS IN
OUR COMMUNITY TO BE AT LEAST AS
RESILIENT AS THEY ARE AND MAKE
DIFFERENT CHOICES AROUND HOUSING
POLICIES THAT WE NO WORK WE HAVE
THE DATA TO PROVE IT.
AND WE JUST NEED TO HAVE THE
COURAGEOUS LEADERSHIP TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE THOSE THINGS HAPPEN I'M
REALLY GRATEFUL TO BE WITH YOU
ALL TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS MOSS --
IS COMMON WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
WHICH IS A RESOURCE AND AN
ADVOCATE FOR FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE CITIES.
IN OUR STATE THERE REPRESENTING
NEARLY THIRTY THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS.
EVEN THOUGH CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
LAWS HAVE CHANGED QUITE
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS WITH OVER THIRTY NEW LAWS
AIMED AT IMPROVING THE LOCAL
PLANNING AND APPROVAL PROCESS.
HOUSING SUPPLY IN AFFORDABILITY
REMAIN CRITICAL ISSUES I DON'T
NEED TO TELL OUR SAY THAT TO
THIS COMMITTEE.
A NO THAT CITIES ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR AND
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. TO DO OUR
PART TO INCREASE HOUSING SUPPLY.
CITIES PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE
THAT WE RECOGNIZE IN THE HOUSING
PRODUCTION PROCESS BY SETTING
THE TABLE SO THAT DEVELOPMENT
CAN HAPPEN.
WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
PLANNING FOR THE ZONING AND FOR
THE APPROVAL OF HOUSING PROJECTS
CONSISTENT WITH THOSE PLANS.
NOW CITIES DON'T BUILD HOUSES
BUT WE DO HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE PLANNING FOR
AND APPROVING THE HOUSING OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED WHILE
MINIMIZING DELAYS COST AND
BARRIERS TO THAT CONSTRUCTION.
THE PLANNING PROCESS REALLY
BEGINS WITH THE CREATION OF THE
CITY'S GENERAL PLAN THIS IS%
REALLY A BLUEPRINT FOR FUTURE
DEVELOPMENT OF ALL KINDS.
AND ANY GOOD PLANNING PROCESS IN
A COMMUNITY IS ONE THAT IS
TRANSPARENT AND ONE THAT IS
INCLUSIVE BY DESIGN WITH
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC OUR RESIDENTS ARE
BUSINESSES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. TO PROVIDE INPUT.
THE GENERAL PLAN AND THE
ASSOCIATED ELEMENTS ARE TRULY A
COMMUNITIES VISION FOR THEIR
FUTURE AM FOR THE PLACE THAT
THEY CALL HOME.
AND IN ANY COMMUNITY.
RESIDENTS FEEL A GREAT SENSE OF
OWNERSHIP OVER THE VISION THEY
HAVE HELPED CREATE.
AND I THINK THAT IS A GOOD THING
AND IT IS ESSENTIAL TO HAVING
THE VIBRANT COMMUNITIES THAT WE
ALL WANT IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT CITIES DON'T PLAN OR ZONE IN
ISOLATION THE STATE IS AN ACTIVE
PARTNER WITH CITIES STATE LAW AS
YOU ALL KNOW REQUIRES EACH
JURISDICTION TO ADOPT A GENERAL
PLAN.
INCLUDING A HOUSING ELEMENT THE
STATE MANDATED PROCESS TO PLAN
AND STONE WHERE ALL OF A
JURISDICTIONS NEEDED HOUSING CAN
ACTUALLY BE BUILT.
THIS INCLUDES ALL TYPES OF
HOUSING AND WE'VE HEARD TODAY
ABOUT THE IMPORTANT NEED FOR THE
SPECTRUM OF AFFORDABILITY FOR
HOUSING. FOR MORE THAN 90% OF
ALL CITIES HAVE A STATE
CERTIFIED HOUSING ELEMENT.
AND WE BELIEVE AS A LEADER
CITIES THAT CITIES SHOULD BE
MEETING THEIR OBLIGATIONS UNDER
THE LAW TO PLAN FOR HOUSING AND
WE ARE WORKING WITH CITIES WHO
ARE NOT IN COMPLIANCE TO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE.
AND PROVIDE SORT TO THEM AS WE
CAN.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE AE UNIQUE FACTORS
AND SENATOR MCGUIRE CHAIRMAN
REQUIRE MENTIONED THIS EARLIER
THERE ARE UNIQUE FACTORS IN PLAY
AND MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES
BETTER IMPACTING THE PLANNING
PROCESS.
IT COULD BE A LACK OF FUNDING TO
HAVE THE PLANNERS ON STAFF --
TO FACILITATE THE ALSO BE LOCAL
CITIZEN OPPOSITION OR IN SOME
CASES EVEN LOCAL BALLOT MEASURES
THAT ARE IMPOSED BY AND PASSED
BY LOCAL CITIZENS WE APPRECIATE
IT AT LEAST FOR THOSE CITIES WHO
ARE NOT IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
STATE LAW WE APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION.
MEETING WITH THEM RECENTLY AND
REALLY TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW
WE CAN HELP THEM GET INTO
COMPLIANCE. ONE QUESTION I'M
OFTEN ASKED I THINK AN EARLIER
SPEAKER REFERENCE THIS IT HAD TO
DO WITH LAND I'M ASKED WE HAVE
ENOUGH LAND ZONED TO MEET OUR
HOUSING NEEDS.
WHEN THE RESEARCH BY UCLA'S
LUSKIN SCHOOL OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS
REPORTS THAT CITIES AND COUNTIES
HAVE ZONE TO LAND FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF TWO POINT EIGHT
MILLION HOMES?
THIS INTO A LITTLE BIT OF
CONTEXT HOME BUILDERS HAVE
PRODUCED AN AVERAGE OF ABOUT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS PER YEAR
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS.
BY MY MATH THAT MEANS CALIFORNIA
HAS ROUGHLY TWENTY EIGHT TIMES
THE AMOUNT OF LAND ZONE FOR
HOUSING.
DâN IS BEING PRODUCED IN ANY
GIVEN YEAR.
ADDITIONALLY A TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REPORT BY THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMIC FORECAST LISTED MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND NEW HOMES.
ARE UNDER CONSTRUCTION OR PROVED
TO BE UNDER CONSTRUCTION BUT
BECAUSE OF FACTORS BEYOND THE
CONTROL OF CITIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THESE HOMES WILL
ACTUALLY NOT BE BILLED FOR AT
LEAST FIVE YEARS.
IN THE PAST TWO YEARS THE LEAGUE
IS STRONGLY SUPPORTED PASSAGE OF
LEGISLATION.
THAT STREAMLINES THE HOUSING
APPROVAL PROCESS THIS INCLUDES
SB FIVE FORTY IT ALSO INCLUDES
AB.
SEVENTY THREE THESE BILLS WHICH
ARE NOW LAW ARE STILL IN THEIR
INFANCY BUT WE'RE WORKING TO GET
THEM IMPLEMENTED.
THE LEAGUE ALSO SUPPORTED THE
PASSAGE OF PROPS ONE AND TWO
WHICH MEANS CITIES WILL FINALLY
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO HELP FIND
THE MUCH NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SUPPORT OF HOUSING
IN OUR COMMUNITIES WHICH YOU
HEARD ABOUT.
EARLIER AND ADDITIONALLY WITH
THE WALKING OF A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS NEXT MONTH FROM
SB TWO FUNDS THANK MANY OF YOU
FOR THAT.
A CITIES WILL HAVE GREATER
RESOURCES TO SOURCES TO
STREAMLINE THE APPROVAL PROCESS
TO ACTUALLY UPDATE OUR LAND USE
PLANS AND ZONE OR TO REZONE TO
MEET THE HOUSING NEEDS.
CITY IS WANT TO BE PARTNERS WITH
THE STATE TO ACHIEVE OUR MUTUAL
HOUSING GOALS WE SUPPORT A
COLLABORATION WITH THE STATE
WHERE THE STATE SETS GOALS AND
PROVIDES INCENTIVES FOR CITIES
THROUGH FUNDING AND PERHAPS A
TAX INCREMENTS.
BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT FIRMLY
AND ULTIMATELY.
THAT THE AUTHORITY THE PLAN FOR
AND HIS OWN AND APPROVE HOUSING
RIGHTFULLY BELONGS IN THE HANDS
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO ARE
CLOSER TO THE GROUND AND CAN
REFLECT THE INTEREST.
OF THOSE WHO LIVE THERE.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE VOTERS
SUPPORT THAT PRINCIPLE AS WELL.
I WANT IN MY REMARKS WERE
TALKING A LITTLE BIT --
ABOUT WHAT WHAT CITY SUPPORT AS
A PART OF THIS LARGER
CONVERSATION WE ARE HAVING.
BESIDES THE RESOURCES IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE'RE ALSO
SUPPORTING WAYS THE STATE CAN
REDUCE LOCAL BARRIERS TO HOUSING
LIKE SOME FORM A SEQUEL REFORM.
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT WE NEED
SUSTAINABLE HOUSING INVESTMENT
PROGRAM AND THAT'S WHY WE
SUPPORT AND APPRECIATE --
CHAIRMAN REQUIRES AND SENATOR
BELLS A LEADERSHIP AND JUMP
STARTING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT A
NEW FORM OF TAX INCREMENTAL
FINANCING.
WE ALSO SUPPORT LOOKING AT
BUILDING FEES IF THERE ARE
BETTER WAYS TO FUND THE SERVICES
AND AMENITIES THAT THESE THESE
PAY.
FOR THE LEAGUE IS OPEN TO HAVING
THAT COMFORTED CONVERSATION.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT THESE ARE
SOMEHOW REDUCE THAT WE SHOULD
MAKE SURE THEIR SAVINGS ARE
PASSED ALONG TO THE BUYER.
WE ALSO SUPPORT REASONABLE
ARCHITECTURAL STANDARDS AND
PARKING REQUIREMENTS AND BELIEVE
THAT NEW SUBDIVISIONS PLANNED BY
CITIES AND DEVELOPERS SHOULD
INCLUDE ZONING FOR MULTI FAMILY
UNITS AND ACCESS FOR HOME BUYERS
IN ALL INCOME RANGES.
AND FINALLY THE LEAGUE SUPPORTS
CITIES RECEIVING THE NEW
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING THAT WE
PROMISED TO VOTERS THAT THEY
WOULD GET UNDER SB.
ONE I WANT TO CLOSE MY REMARKS
WITH A SOME COMMENTS ARE SOME
WORDS THAT I'LL BORROW FROM --
HARVEY MILK MAKE NO MISTAKE
ABOUT THIS THE AMERICAN DREAM
STARTS WITH THE NEIGHBORHOODS IF
WE WISH TO REBUILD OUR CITIES WE
MUST FIRST REBUILD OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE SOME REMARKS TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
TO THE PANEL --
SO --
COLLEAGUES IS ANYONE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
CENTER MORLOCKS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISSED
RENSSELAER'S I'D LIKE TO START
WITH YOU --
YOU YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU HAD
TO SEVENTY THOUSAND AFFORDABLE
HOMES THAT YOU'VE CREATED ARE
PRESERVED OVER THE LAST.
SOME THIRTY ONE YEARS.
NOT ME BUT YS --
I THAT'S ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED UNITS A YEAR I'M JUST
CURIOUS.
WHAT IS YOUR BEEN YOUR YEAR BY
YEAR --
RESULTS I DON'T HAVE THE NUMBER
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD I THINK --
AS THE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT PROGRAM HAS GROWN OVER
TIME.
AND BECOME MORE --
THE MAINSTAY FUNDING SOURCE FOR
ANY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION --
PRESERVATION THE STATE.
AND AS THE INDUSTRY HAS GROWN
AROUND THAT OUR STAFF IN OUR
ABILITY TO HELP DEVELOPERS AND
LOCAL AGENCIES BUILD HOUSING IS
GROWING OVER TIME SO IT'S LIKE
IT'S BEEN A PRETTY STEADY
INCREASE --
THERE CERTAINLY WAS A DROP OFF
IN THE RECESSION BUT IT'S
BASICALLY BASED ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF RESOURCES --
SO YOU KNOW WE OUR OUR WORK
BASICALLY FOLLOWS THAT YEAH INTO
THEM WHAT'S BEEN THE SECRET TO
YOUR SUCCESS YOU FINING LAND OR
YOU JUST REHABILITATING.
EXISTING PROPERTIES SO WE
PROVIDE FINANCIAL CONSULTING --
AND WORK WITH DEVELOP NONPROFIT
THESE AND THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
IDENTIFY THE LAND --
WE HELP THEM SORT OF A SYMBOL
THE FINANCING NEGOTIATE WITH
INVESTORS AND THAT KIND OF THING --
SO WE PLAY SORT OF DISCRETE ROLE
IN THAT VERY COMPLICATED PROCESS
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IN PARTICULAR.
AND THEN --
ON PAGE.
THIRTEEN OF YOUR PRESENTATION.
FOR THE FAR RIGHT.
A WRY PART THE LOW INCOME AND
MODERATE HI INCOME --
EIGHT EIGHT FOR FOR BLACKS IS
THAT WAITED.
IN OTHER WORDS.
IS JUSTICE JUST REFLECT THE THE
BLACK POPULATION OR IF.
THE BLACK POPULATION IS SAY 8%
OF THE POPULATION WOULD CHANGE.
THE NUMBERS I JUST.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND WHAT I WHAT I
YEAH -- SO
THE THIS IS A SHARE OF TOTAL SO
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT SO SO YES
TYPICALLY --
BLACK HOUSEHOLDS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO BE LOW INCOME DUE TO DECADES
OF DISCRIMINATION AND ALL KINDS
OF FACTORS LIKE THAT --
BUT IF WE'RE LOOKING AT WITHIN
THE UNIVERSE OF MODERATE TO HANG
COMPLY COUNCILS IN THE BAY AREA --
WITHOUT REGARD TO THEIR TOTAL
NUMBERS WHERE THEY LEFT.
AND THEY'RE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO
LIVE IN POOR.
SEGREGATED LOW RESOURCE
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE BAY AREA
MUCH.
MUCH MORE SO THAN EVEN LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS [inaudible]
AND THEN.
THANK YOU HAVE A QUESTION FOR MR
GARCIA BUT I HAVE MISSED IT SO
MISTER CARROLL.
THANK YOU CENTER MELAKA CENTER
SKINNER.
THANK YOU AND WHILE I WASN'T IN
THE ROOM I WAS LISTENING TO THE
HEARING.
DEALING WITH SOME THINGS I HAD
TO SIGN.
SO I HAVE A QUESTION FORMR
INSULAR BECAUSE YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE RED LINING AND OTHER
POLICIES THAT HAVE --
RACIALLY IMPACTED OUR HAVE
AFFECTED THE SEGREGATION IN THE
RACIAL AM OPPORTUNITIES IN
DISPARITIES IN OUR HOUSING.
COULD YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW ZONING HAS --
IN AFFECTED THAT.
YEAH WELL WE WE DID NOT INCLUDE
AN ANALYSIS OF ZONING AND OUR I
TRY TO GET TO THE SIDE.
IN OUR ANALYSIS BUT YOU CAN KIND
OF SEE THE THE AREAS THAT ARE
NOT --
RACIALLY SEGREGATED IN HIGH
POVERTY ARE TYPICALLY WIDER --
LOWER DENSITIES OWNED AREAS AND
SO THEY'VE. ONE OF THE TOOLS
THEY HAVE USED TO ALLOW --
TO BLOCK CERTAIN GROUPS OF
PEOPLE FROM LIVING IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES HAS BEEN ZONING AND
SO WHEN WE HAVE HOUSING RICES
RISING IN THE URBAN CORE.
AND LOW INCOME PEOPLE OF COLOR
ARE DISPLACED THEY'RE THEY'RE
SORT OF BY PASSING THOSE --
SINGLE FAMILIES ON HIGHER INCOME
AREAS AND ENDING UP THE URBAN
PERIPHERY WHICH YOU CAN KIND OF
SEE AN IN THIS SHIFTING
LANDSCAPE OF WHERE LONGER PEOPLE
OF COLOR LIVE IN THE BAY AREA --
AND AND THIS PART I DIDN'T HEAR
IF ANYONE HAD REFERENCE BUT DID
ANYONE REFERENCE THE RECENT --
REPORT THAT SHOWS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHEN BANKS WERE EXAMINED
FOR LOANS AND THIS IS JUST IN
THE LAST. TWO TO FOUR YEARS.
IN EVERY MAJOR CITY IN THE
UNITED STATES INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA.
YOUR ABILITY TO GET A LOAN.
WAS IT INDEPENDENT OF ALL OTHER
FACTORS OF INCOME CREDIT SCORE.
WERE WAS IMPACTED ON THE BASIS
OF YOUR RACE AND IF YOU WERE
BLACK.
YOUR AT YOUR LIKELIHOOD OF THE
LOAN.
DROPPED BY A SIGNIFICANT
PERCENTAGE POINT.
DID ANYONE NINE REFERENCE THAT
STUDY.
WE DIDN'T BUT I WOULD SAY THAT
THAT VERY MUCH MIRRORS OUR
FINDINGS THAT RACE SEEMS TO BE A
MUCH MORE POWERFUL FACTOR IN
DETERMINING WHAT YOU HAVE ACCESS.
TO THEN INCOME --
AND I THINK THAT IT IT IT.
WHOSE US TO TALK MORE ABOUT RACE
EXPLICITLY AND HOUSING AND LAND
USE POLICY.
THANK YOU.
KNOW CLEARLY ARE HEARING TODAY
IS ABOUT THE HOUSING --
SERVE EMERGENCY CALIFORNIA'S SAN.
BUT I RAISE THOSE ISSUES BECAUSE
AS WE THINK ABOUT HOW TO ADDRESS
IT.
I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE A
CAREFUL LENS SO THAT WE IN
ADDRESSING IT DON'T EXACERBATE.
THESE RACIAL DISPARITIES AND
I'VE SAID THIS IS THIS COMMITTEE
NUMBER TIMES BUT I WOULD
RECOMMEND.
THE BOOK THE COLOR OF LAW.
WHICH DOCUMENTS QUITE CLEAR NOT
JUST -- RED
LINING IN MORTGAGE POLICIES BUT
LITERALLY THE HISTORY.
OF ZONING.
AND HOW --
THE EXPANSION OF OUR ONE ZONING
AT DIFFERENT TIMES IN THE U. S.
HISTORY IN RESPONSE TO WHETHER
IT WAS EXPLICITLY SAID OR NOT.
BUT THEY WERE SIGNIFICANT JUMPS
IN EFFORTS TO DOWN ZONE AFTER
THINGS LIKE THE PASSAGE OF THE
FAIR HOUSING ACT.
AND THE COURT RULING IN THE
CIGARETTE INTEGRATION OF SCHOOLS.
SO THERE'S QUITE A LOT OF GOOD
DOCUMENTATION AROUND.
BE RACIAL AND ECONOMIC.
EXPLICIT RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
EXCLUSION.
PURPOSE OF SINGLE FAMILY ZONING.
I'M THANK YOU SIR SKINNER AND I
WON JUST.
REITERATE --
DIE -- YOU
KNOW AND I GREW UP IN A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME IN A SINGLE FAMILY
HOME.
OUR COMMUNITY WORK BUT IT WAS
YOU KNOW --
YOU KNOW AND THIS IS SO COMMON
WHERE YOU IN SO MANY --
SUBURBAN AREAS IN PARTICULAR IT
SINGLE FAMILY HOME IN THE NEW
ONE PART OF TOWN.
DEAD ZONE FOR MULTI UNIT AND
THAT'S WERE LOW INCOME PEOPLE
LIVE AND IT ABSOLUTELY
PERPETUATE SEGREGATION --
AND YOU KNOW SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
OWNING WASN'T IT STRUCK DOWN
RACIAL ZONING AND SO --
I THINK WE NEED TO GRAPPLE WITH
THAT HISTORY AND AND TODAY IT'S
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT A IT IS NOT.
THAT IT'S ABOUT THE FACT NO I'M --
AND SO --
WHICH IS SOMETHING WE HAVE TO
OUR AND GRAPPLE WITH. ONE THING
I WANT TO ASK FOR NON THIS
COLEMAN I APPRECIATE YOUR
REMARKS AND I'VE ENJOYED WORKING
WITH THE LEAGUE EVEN THOUGH I
DON'T ALWAYS AGREE.
ON WELL AND ONE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I REALLY TRY.
I WOULD LOVE TO MOVE THE
CONVERSATION AWAY FROM IS
THERE'S THIS WHOLE NOTION OF SO
THE GOOD ACTORS CITIES IN THE
BAD ACTORS CITIES.
AND THE BAD ACTORS CITIES
PUNISHMENT SO THEY GET TO TAKE
MORE HOUSING AND THE GOOD ACTORS
CITIES GET A GET A PASS AND OF
COURSE WE WANT ALL CITIES TO
COMPLY WITH THE LAW.
AND YOU KNOW THERE YES SIR THE
FORTY SEVEN CITIES THAT ARE NOT
IN COMPLIANCE WITH HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW --
ONE WAS SUED --
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT HOUSING PRODUCTION --
TWO THIRDS OF CITIES THIS IS
ABOUT --
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY MUCH BIGGER THAN
THE FORTY SEVEN WHO MAY HAVE
PERFECTLY COMPLIANT.
HOUSING ELEMENTS TWO THIRDS ARE
NOT MEETING THE RENO GOALS AT
ANY.
INCOME LEVEL SO THESE ARE CITIES
THAT HAVE.
THEY MIGHT HAVE BEAUTIFUL
HOUSING ELEMENTS THAT ARE
PERFECTLY COMPLIANCE WITH A NOT
MEAN THEIR GOALS BECAUSE PEOPLE
DON'T LIVE IN HOUSING ELEMENTS
PEOPLE LIVING.
IN HOMES --
AND SO [inaudible]
IT'S TO ME IT'S NOT ABOUT WHO'S
A GOOD ACTORS IS A BAD ACTOR
IT'S ABOUT.
WHAT?
WHAT IS THE STRUCTURE THAT WE'VE
CREATED? FOR HOUSING --
BECAUSE YOU KNOW HE SOMETIMES
CITIES AND CITY COUNCILS MAYORS
COULD DEMONIZED --
AND I DON'T BY PERSONAL AGREE
WITH OVERWHELMINGLY PEOPLE OR A
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICER THERE YOU
KNOW FOR THE RIGHT REASONS
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO SERVE THE
COMMUNITY AND GET THE LITTLEOR
NOTHING AND GET YELLED AT A LOT.
YOU KNOW BY PEOPLE --
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS HAD HOW DO
WE CREATE A STRUCTURE THAT
FACILITATES.
AN OF HOUSING WITHOUT ANY
BLAMING OF ANYONE.
ON AND SO MY MY QUESTION FOR YOU
IS.
DOES THE STRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE
TODAY [inaudible]
WHICH IS.
LARA OVERWHELMINGLY UNTIL VERY
RECENTLY --
LOCAL CONTROL THERE ARE STATE
LAWS THAT DIDN'T GET ENFORCED
VERY MUCH --
LOT OF LOCAL DECISION MAKING ON
HAVE WERE GOING TO ALLOW NEW
HOUSING HOW MUCH WE'RE GOING TO
ALLOW OR GOING TO BAN EVERYTHING
EXCEPT FOR SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
OR WE GONNA ALLOW FOR MULTI YEAR.
THREE FOUR FIVE YEARS TEN YEARS
TO APPROVE THE ZONING FOR
PLANNED PROJECTS --
WITH CREATED THE SYSTEM AND AND
A STATE RESPONSIBILITY --
TO WE KNOW THEIR SITUATIONS WERE
SEE C<c.cyan> CAN --</c>
THE LADY ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE HOUSING.
WHEN WE HAVE TO ADD IF ONE
AGREES THAT WE HAVE A THREE AND
A HALF POINT ON DEFICIT HOW?
WHAT WE NEED TO DO? TO GET THERE
IT'S A LOT RACHEL IS A LOT OF
HOUSING AND SO --
AT WHAT WHAT DO WAY TO GET THERE
IS COMMON HOW MUCH IS HOW MUCH
TIME YOU CAN JUMP ME.
WIENER.
OF THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND AND THE SENTIMENT
AND I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE NEED --
TO TO PAY ATTENTION TO EQUITY
AND THE INEQUITIES IN IN THE
SYSTEMS THAT WE MAY HAVE --
TODAY WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO GET
THERE I THINK WE'RE AT A MOMENT
IN.
I SEE MY SHORT HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA I'VE ONLY BEEN HERE
FOR TWO YEARS BUT IN TWO YEARS
I'VE BEEN HERE.
THIS CONVERSATION HAS BEEN TOP
OF MIND --
pMEMBERSHIP.
THAT IS BEEN A PRIORITY WHAT WE
DO ABOUT HOUSING AND HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY HAS BEEN AT THE
TOP OF THE LIST.
A SINCE I STEPPED FOOT INTO THE
STATE -- I
THINK THERE ARE NO EASY ANSWERS
AND I DON'T TAKE SAME OUT
LIGHTLY --
BUT THERE ARE --
THERE ARE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES AND OBLIGATIONS
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE
CITY OFFICIALS HAVE TO THEIR
RESIDENCE --
BUT AS WE HAVE HEARD DESCRIBED A
LITTLE BIT --
FROM THE OTHER PANELISTS TODAY --
AND IN THE BACKGROUND THERE.
THERE ARE MANY FOR THAT MAKE UP
WHAT WE CALL THE HOUSING
PRODUCTION SYSTEM IN THE STATE.
AND I THINK --
IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A BETTER
SYSTEM TOMORROW.
THAT GETS US TO YES TO MORE
HOUSING TOMORROW.
ON THEN IT IS INCUMBENT FOR ALL
OF THE STAKEHOLDERS TO BE AT THE
TABLE HAVING A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE MANY DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES AND FACTORS.
THAT MAKE UP WHAT WE CALL
HOUSING SYSTEM YES.
THERE ARE THINGS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NEED TO DO BETTER
MUST DO BETTER AS WE HEAD INTO
THE FUTURE YOU ALL HAVE --
HELPED US DO MORE OF THAT WITH
THE FUNDING THAT YOU HAVE
PROVIDED SET THOSE COMMUNITIES
THAT DON'T HAVETHE PLAN
CAPACITY THAT THEY MIGHT NEED
HAVE THAT CAPACITY.
SO -- YOU
KNOW WE'RE GOING TO BE FOCUSED
ON ON DOING OUR PART BUT WE
CAN'T IGNORE THE WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES AND ISSUES --
IN OUR STATE --
WE CAN'T IGNORE THE IMPACT THAT --
THE TENSION BETWEEN --
DESIRING A CLEAN REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS --
AND THE USE OF OTHER TOOLS TO
HELP INTERFERE.
WITH THAT HOUSING --
I I THINK AT SOME POINT WORLD I
HOPE WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT ALL
OF THESE THINGS MUST BE ON THE
TABLE FOR AN HONEST CONVERSATION.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT --
YOUR I CAN AGREE ON THE SET --
THERE'S OF COURSE NO ONE SILVER
BULLET BUT NO ZONING PROCESS
FUNDING CETERA ON IT ALL HAS TO
BE ON TABLES ARE PROJECT THAT
[inaudible]
REQUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER.
BUT THIS TO GO FOR A ALL FAURIA
AND JUST.
GET INTO SOME SPECIFICS WILL
AGREE THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL
ITEMS THAT ARE IN FRONT OF US
THAT WE ARE HAVING CHALLENGES
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
CONTINUE TACKLE.
I THINK --
ONE OF THE LARGEST ITEMS THAT WE
HAVE THOUGH ARE THOSE ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION FOR DOUBLE UNITS --
THAT BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE'RE GONNA
BE SHORT.
WAS OUR MARKET THOSE ARE
AFFORDABLE RENTALS IN FACT I
EIGHTY DAYS PREDICTION ABOUT A
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND MARKET
SURPLUS IN THAT SAME TIME PERIOD
WHEN IT COMES TO MARGUERITE
RENTALS.
A SALE THAT IS.
I DON'T WANNA TALK ABOUT
SPECIFIC BILLS HERE TODAY IS --
CENTER WINNER AND I CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS I DO WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE STRATEGIC
CAN FILL IN THAT STREAMLINING.
BECAUSE WHAT IT SEEMS LIKE.
IS THERE IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE
SOME APPROACH. TO BE ABLE TO GET
HOUSING BUILT FASTER.
IN AREAS WHERE --
HOUSING HAS ALREADY BEEN SEWN
[inaudible] FOR THEY LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO GET YOUR TAKE.
ON THAT --
BECAUSE THE BOTTOM LINE ON HOW
WE GET THERE ARE NO EASY ANSWERS.
AND TO BE ABLE TO EXPEDITE THE
PROCESS --
ON LOOKING AT A STRATEGIC
APPROACH OR AREAS OF ALREADY
BEEN SOWN FOR HOUSING.
AND TO BE ABLE TO STREAM THAT
PROCESS TO BE ABLE TO GET THE
BELT AND I COULD COMMENT ON THAT.
IF YOU THINK THAT'S ONE OF OUR
TOP TOOLS IN ABOUT.
NOT ALL AT ONCE SO --
CHAIRMAN OUT I'VE BEEN HAPPY TO
TO CHIME IN ON ON THIS --
ONE YOU KNOW.
IN THE LAST AGAIN I LOOK AT THE
LAST TWO YEARS --
A COUPLE OF THE TOOLS THAT I
THINK --
WILL HELP ACCELERATE A GETTING
HOUSES BUILT GETTING AFFORDABLE
HOUSES BUILT OUR PROP ONE AND
AND PROP --
TO WE AT UNDERSTAND IN THE STATE
YEARS AGO THERE WAS A DIFFERENT
SOURCE.
OF ON GOING FINANCING THAT
HELPED PRODUCE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING --
THAT RESOURCE NO LONGER EXIST
AND THEIR EFFORTS UNDER WAY TO
AT LEAST HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT A REPLACEMENT --
BUT I THINK PROP ONE IN --
SIX TOWARDS --
GETTING MORE HOUSES PRODUCED
QUICKLY I THINK IF WE CAN --
SEE A NEW VERSION TODAY'S
VERSION OF TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING --
I THINK THAT WILL GO A LONG WAY
TO GETTING MORE AFFORDABLE UNITS --
UNITS BUILT I THINK --
WITH SOME OF THE PLANNING
DOLLARS FROM SB TWO I THINK AND
I BELIEVE THOSE FUNDS ARE GOING
TO START TO FLOW --
IN JUST A COUPLE OF MONTHS THAT --
CITIES AROUND THE STATE --
WILL BE --
TAKING UP THE OFFER OF THOSE
RESOURCES AND STREAMLINING THEIR
PROCESS SEES AND ALSO UPDATING
THEIR PLANS AND AND THERE'S
OWNING SO I THINK THERE ARE SOME
VERY IMPORTANT TOOLS.
THAT YOU ALL AND ARE VOTERS HAVE
PUT INTO PLACE EVEN IN JUST THE
LAST YEAR THAT WILL HELP
ACCELERATE OR AT LEAST JUMPSTART.
SOME AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION THAT PROBABLY
WASN'T HAPPENING A YEAR AGO BUT
I SUSPECT KNOWING OF MY CITIES
THE WAY I DO ABOUT WERE PROBABLY
PLANNED WAITING FOR RESOURCES.
TO GET THOSE UNDER WAY.
THE RABBIT JUST ADD --
I THINK THAT WE HAVE A MYRIAD OF
CHALLENGES THAT ARE CONTRIBUTING
TO OUR TO OUR ISSUE AND AND SO
YOU YOU REALLY FIGURING OUT HOW
DO I HOW TO TACKLE IT FROM
MULTIPLE DIRECTIONS.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY BUILD OURSELVES
OUT OF THIS PROBLEM WHEN A UNIT
OF HOUSING COSTS SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO BUILD.
AFFORDABLE UNIT RIGHT SO THE
CONSTRUCTION STATE OF ALL WE
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BRING
DOWN COSTS IF WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO BRING MORE UNITS ONLINE
FASTER WHICH THEN LEADS LEADS TO
HOW DO WE LOOK AT DIFFERENT
TYPOLOGIES.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO TALK WITH
OUR LABOR COMMUNITY AND OUR
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT MODULAR
HOUSING ABOUT HOW DO WE BRING
NEW CONSTRUCTION ON FASTER --
SO I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
COMPONENTS I THINK ANOTHER
CHALLENGE WE HAVE IS.
EVEN IF WE WERE ABLE TO WE WERE
ZONE FOR ALL THE HOUSING WE
NEEDED --
AND WE WERE ABLE TO BUILD IT WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH LABOR TO
ACTUALLY BUILD IT SO FIGURING
OUT HOW DO WE LOOK AT THE LABOR
PIPELINE SO THAT THERE ARE
ENOUGH PEOPLE WHO CAN ACTUALLY
DO THE CONSTRUCTION OF NEW
HOUSING --
ACTED ACQUISITION REHABS I MEAN
WE NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT NOT
WHO IS CURRENTLY IN THE LABOR
MARKET IN OUR LABOR UNIONS BUT
HOW DO WE LOOK AT OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE HOW DO WE TAP INTO --
YOU KNOW YOUNG PEOPLE IN OAKLAND
FOR EXAMPLE WHO BY BY THE TIME
THEY REACHED HIGH SCHOOL ARE NOT
FINISHING HIGH SCHOOL HOW DO WE
GET THOSE FOLKS INTERESTED IN
THE TRADES.
SO HOT WE HAVE TO BE MUCH MORE%
CREATIVE AND DYNAMIC AROUND OUR
SOLUTIONS AND BE ABLE TO COME AT
IT FROM DIFFERENT.
LEVELS SO THAT ALL STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY IN CAN SEE
THEMSELVES IN THE SOLUTIONS.
MY COMMENTS ARE GONNA BE ABOUT
THE COST OF CONSTRUCTION.
BUT I'LL I'LL JUST REITERATE A
COUPLE THINGS --
WE WE DO HAVE SOME TREMENDOUS
NEW RESOURCES --
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING --
THINK THANKS TO THE LEGISLATURE
BUT TO THE EXTENT TO WHICH COSTS
KEEP RISING THOSE DOLLARS ARE
GOING TO BECOME LESS AND LESS
EFFICIENT WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
BUILD.
AS MANY HOMES AS ARE NECESSARY
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM --
SO JUST TO KEEP THAT IN MIND AND
THEN I THINK WE ALSO GET CAUGHT
IN THIS -- A
DISCUSSION OF WHAT ARE WE
ACTUALLY BUILDING ARE WE
BUILDING REALLY DENSE TALL
HOUSING --
OR WE ONLY BUILDING --
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES OF PLACES
ONE OF ARCHER'S CENTER FOLLOWS
THAT SHE DOES REALLY GOOD WORK
ON THIS --
AND WE HAVE LARGE.
SWATHS OF LAND WHERE YOU HAVE NO
BUILDING --
WHATSOEVER OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
DECADES --
IT IN SO TO THE EXTENT TO WHICH
WE CAN TALK ABOUT DIFFERENT
BUILDING TYPOLOGIES SO MISSING
MIDDLE HOUSING THINGS LIKE
DUPLEXES AND PRACTICES --
AND WHERE THAT FITS INTO OUR
EXISTING LAND USE PATTERNS I
THINK THAT'S A REALLY KEY
COMPONENT AS THIS TYPE OF
HOUSING IS INHERENTLY CHEAPER TO
BUILD CAN BE BUILT FASTER --
AND DOES NOT NECESSARILY DISRUPT
THE EXISTING CHARACTER MANY OF
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS --
SO -- I'LL
HELLO LEAVE IT AT THAT.
SENATE MCGUIRE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THAT THE STATE'S INVESTMENT IN
HOUSING SHOULD FOCUS ON MEETING
THAT ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR HOME.
GAP THAT YOU IDENTIFIED THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IT'S A CRISIS
DISPROPORTIONATELY BORNE BY LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS --
AND SO WE WE NEED MORE PUBLIC
INVESTMENT ABSOLUTELY FROM THE
STATE AND AND LOCALLY.
I'LL JUST MAKE A PLUG YOU KNOW
WE MAY ALSO NEED LANDS THAT HIS
OWN TO ALLOW FOR MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING WHICH IS.
A CHEAPER ON A PER UNIT BASIS TO
BUILD.
AND ST CHEAPER TO LIVE IN --
SO THAT WE CAN BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND ALSO APARTMENT
BUILDINGS THAT ARE LARGE ENOUGH
TO TRIGGER AN INCLUSIONARY
POLICY.
THAT SO THEY HAVE AFFORDABLE
UNITS IN THEM --
CLOSE TO TRANSIT YES IT'S THAT
HAVE.
A TYPICALLY RESISTED APARTMENT
BUILDINGS HISTORICALLY WHICH MAY
NOT BE RIGHT NEXT TO TRANSIT BUT
THEY MIGHT BE CLOSE TO JOB
CENTERS AND SO BUILDING THERE
WOULD ALLOW.
THAT KIND OF RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
INTEGRATION THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT AND ALSO SHORTER DRIVING
COMMUTES OVERALL SO THAT SHOULD
BE PART OF THE STATE'S STRATEGY.
THANK YOU OKAY ANY OTHER.
YOUR QUESTION SEEING NONE --
I WANT TO THANK OUR FIRST PANEL --
WE APPRECIATE IT WILL NOW MOVE
TO OUR SECOND --
PANEL THE IMPACTS ON HOUSING
STATE PLANNING A REQUIREMENTS.
AND SO WE CAN DO A LITTLE
TRANSITION HERE.
AND BRING UP THE SECOND BOTTLE
.
OKAY SO WE HAVE --
TWO PANELISTS ON THIS NEXT PANEL
UNTIL IMPACTS ON HOUSING STATE
PLAN REQUIREMENTS --
WE HAVE MAKING KERR COULD BE WHO
IS THE ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR FAIR HOUSING OF THE HOUSING
POLICY DIVISION.
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
THE LONG TITLE --
AND WE HAVE VALERIE FELDMAN IS A
STAFF ATTORNEY THE WITH THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT SO
WELCOME -- I
WILL START WITH A MISS KIRBY AND
THEN HEAR FROM INSTALLMENT AND
AGAIN I WOULD ASK YOU TO KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO FIVE MINUTES OR
SO THAT WOULD BE GREAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME.
HERE TODAY AND OF COURSE I COULD
SPEND THREE HOURS TALKING ABOUT
THE REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS-ASSESSMENT BUT WE'LL.
KEEP IT HIGH LEVEL TODAY --
AS THE REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT HAS ALWAYS BEEN
ROOTED IN FAIR HOUSING IN
REDUCING THE CONCENTRATIONS OF
POVERTY AND SEGREGATION THROUGH
PLANNING.
THE STATUTORY OBJECTIVES OF RENO
INCLUDE INCREASING HOUSING
SUPPLY IN A MIX OF HOUSING TYPES
PROMOTING INFILL DEVELOPMENT.
AND IMPROVE IN A REGIONAL JOBS
HOUSING RELATIONSHIP --
BALANCING DISPROPORTIONATE
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES --
AND WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE LAST YEAR.
THERE WAS THE ADDITION OF THE
AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHERING FAIR
HOUSING.
REQUIREMENT IN THE STATUTORY
OBJECTIVES OF RENO REALLY.
REAFFIRMING THIS LINK TO FAIR
HOUSING --
AS WELL AS SOME ADDITIONAL
CHANGES --
IN THE BOLD LANGUAGE.
THE RENO PROCESS BEGINS WITH H.
CITY IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
DEMOGRAPHIC RESEARCH UNIT AS
WELL AS THE COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENT.
DEVELOPING A REGIONAL HOUSING
NEED DETERMINATION ACROSS FOR
INCOME CATEGORIES USING A
VARIETY OF FACTORS THAT I'LL GO
THROUGH ON THE NEXT SLIDE.
INCLUDING SOME NEW FACTORS THAT
HAVE BEEN ADDED BY SB EIGHT TO
EIGHT AND AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
ONE THIS YEAR.
H. C. D. MUST PROVIDE THE
DETERMINATION AT LEAST TWO YEARS
BEFORE HOUSING ELEMENT DUE DATE
THAT LEAVES ONE YEAR FOR THE
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENT TO A RUN
THROUGH THEIR PROCESS.
AND ONE YEAR FOR THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION.
TO BUT IN LARGER REGIONS --
EIGHTY PROVIDES THE
DETERMINATION MUCH EARLIER TO
ALLOW MORE TIME FOR THE REGIONAL
GOVERNMENT. TO PROVIDE ITS
REGIONAL HOUSING NEED ALLOCATION
AND DISTRIBUTION PROCESS.
THAT REGIONAL HOUSING --
NEED ALLOCATION AND DISTRIBUTION
PROCESS.
BUT IS THE BLUE SECTION BUT
THERE'S ALSO NEW STATUTE THIS
YEAR THROUGH AB THE PASSAGE OF
AB.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE THE NOW
PROVIDES EACH CD THE ABILITY TO
REVIEW OF THE COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS METHODOLOGY OF HOW
THEY PLAN TO DO THAT ALLOCATION.
AND GIVES IT TO THE THE ABILITY
TO APPEAL --
THAT ALLOCATION IF IT.
DOES NOT FURTHER THE STATUTORY
OBJECTIVES ARENA.
THE THERE ARE SEVERAL A TWENTY
RURAL COUNTIES IN THE NORTH
STATE AND SIERRA PARTS THE STATE.
WHERE IT'S H. CITY AXES THE
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS SO NOT
ONLY DOES THE DEPARTMENT
DETERMINE THE REGIONAL HOUSING
NEED ON A REGIONAL LEVEL --
FOR THOSE COUNTIES BUT WE ALSO
ACT AS THEIR COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENT GIVING EACH
JURISDICTION THEIR ALLOCATION OF
RINA.
THEN THAT PROCESS MOVES TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
WHATEVER RINA ALLOCATION THAT
THEY'VE BEEN GIVEN --
THEY USED TO PRODUCE THEIR HOUSE
THE HOUSING PLAN OF THEIR
GENERAL PLAN --
AND PROVIDE THAT HOUSING PLAN
BACK TO HDD TO SHOW THAT THEY
HAVE SUFFICIENT ZONING TO MEET
THAT REGIONAL HOUSING NEED
ALLOCATION.
AS WELL AS PROGRAMS AND POLICIES.
TO REDUCE.
BARRIERS AS WELL AS ENCOURAGE
DEVELOPMENT TO HAPPEN AND THE
DEPARTMENT REVIEWS AND APPROVES
THOSE PLANS.
SO THE THAT EACH CITY SIDE OF
THE REGIONAL HOUSING NEED --
IS SHOWN ON THIS SLIDE HERE.
THAT THE REGIONAL NUMBER EIGHTY
PROVIDES THE COG IS TO THE
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENT IS
DETERMINED STARTING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PROJECTIONS.
DETERMINE THE NUMBER OF
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE PROJECTED TO
LIVE IN THE REGION AT THE END OF
THE CYCLE.
AND EACH CITY ADDRESS THE
HOUSING NEEDS --
BEYOND THIS TO ACCOUNT FOR
PARTICULAR FACTORS.
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE THIS
YEAR ADDED UNITS LOST DUE TO AN
EMERGENCY AND SB EIGHT TWO EIGHT
ADDED CLARITY AROUND
OVERCROWDING AND THE VACANCY
RATE AS FACTORS.
AN ADDED COST BURDEN IS A NEW
FACTOR.
SB EIGHT TWO EIGHT ALSO CODIFIED
THAT THESE FACTORS.
ARE MEANT TO ADDRESS THE OVERALL
HOUSING NEED.
SO ONCE THAT WE TAKE THE PROJECT
HOUSEHOLDS ON AT THE END OF THIS
CYCLE AND WE ADJUSTED BASED ON
THESE FACTORS.
WITHIN SUBTRACT OUT HOW MANY
UNITS THERE ARE TODAY IN THAT
REGION UP FROM THAT NUMBER TO
GET THAT GAP OF WHAT WE NEED TO
SEE PRODUCED OVER THE NEXT CYCLE
AND THAT IS THE REGIONAL HOUSING
NEEDS ASSESSMENT --
THE EIGHTY PROVIDES TO THE
COUNCIL OF THE COUNCIL
GOVERNMENT MUST THEN TAKE THIS
REGIONAL NUMBER AND CONSIDER
STATUTORY FACTORS IN ITS
ALLOCATION TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN ADDITION TO THE STATUTORY
OBJECTIVES I MENTIONED AT THE
BEGINNING.
MOST OF THESE FACTORS EXISTED IN
PRIOR CYCLES BUT AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY ONE NOW REQUIRES COUNCIL
OF GOVERNMENTS RIDE MORE
DOCUMENTATION ON HOW THE FACTORS
ARE USED IN THE METHODOLOGY.
AND EACH CITY CAN REVIEW THE
METHODOLOGY TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
FURTHERS THE STATUTORY
OBJECTIVES.
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE AND SB
A TO A ALSO MADE ADDITIONAL
CHANGES THE SECTION TO ADD
OVERCROWDING LOTS OF UNITS
DURING AN EMERGENCY.
GHG EMISSION TARGETS AS FACTORS
THE COG MUST CONSIDER.
AND WHEN OTHER FACTORS --
ARE YOU SORT OF THIS --
BLANKET THAT THAT THE COG HAS
THE ABILITY TO ADD OTHER FACTORS
THAT MIGHT NOT BE PART OF THIS
LIST THEY MUST BE SHOWN TO NOT
BE IN CONFLICT WITH THE
STATUTORY OBJECTIVES.
SB EIGHT TWO EIGHT ALSO
PROHIBITED THE COUNCILS OF
GOVERNMENT FROM USING PASSED
UNDER PRODUCTION AS A REASON FOR
RINA.
WE ARE NOW AT THE END OF THE
FIFTH CYCLE OF THE HOUSING
ELEMENT.
SO THAT TIME LINE SHOWN HERE --
ARE FOR THE FIFTH CYCLE AND WE
ARE NOW JUST EMBARKING ON THE
BEGINNING OF THE SIX CYCLE OF
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS.
ASSESSMENT PREPARATION SO THE
SAN DIEGO --
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS ALSO
KNOWN -- HAS
RECEIPT RECEIVED THEIR DRUG
THERE --
FINAL ALLOCATION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT --
AND THEY ARE NOW IN THE PROCESS
OF DEVELOPING THEIR METHODOLOGY --
TO ALLOCATE THAT TO THEIR
JURISDICTIONS.
WHERE IS THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS AND
THE SACRAMENTO ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS WILL RECEIVE THEIR --
AT DRAFT ASSESSMENTS FROM MARINA
ON IN THE OVER THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS.
I WOULD THINK IT'S HELPFUL.
TO EXPLAIN THAT THE REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT IS A
PROJECTION OF ADDITIONAL HOUSING
UNITS NEEDED TO ACCOMMODATE
PROJECTED HOUSEHOLD GROWTH.
OF ALL INCOME LEVELS FROM THE
START UNTIL THE END OF THE
PROJECTION PERIOD.
SO IT IS NOT A PREDICTION OF HOW
MUCH --
PERMITTING WE EXPECT TO HAPPEN
AND IT CERTAINLY IS NOT A
CEILING OF HOW MUCH HOUSING --
DEMANDER PRODUCTION SHOULD OCCUR
AND IT IS NOT LIMITED DUE TO
EXISTING LAND USE CAPACITY OR
GROWTH CONTROL REZONING IS OFTEN
NECESSARY FOR JURISDICTIONS TO
ACCOMMODATE THEIR THEIR ARENA
[inaudible]
AT THE REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT HOUSING ELEMENTS --
AND A LOT OF THE CHANGES THAT
COME FROM THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
HOUSING PACKAGE --
WILL MAKE SIX CYCLE A FRIEND AND
ARE TOO MUCH TO COVER IN A SHORT
TIME TODAY BUT YOU CAN FIND MORE
INFORMATION ON ALL OF THOSE ON
OUR WEBSITE --
OR WE ARE AVAILABLE IF YOU HAVE
ANY FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER KARIM
I ALSO WON A SISTER PUBLICLY
THANK.
EACH CD I'M HAVING THE AUTHORED
BY TWO BILLS IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS THAT REQUIRED DOT.
QUICK IMPLEMENTATION SB THIRTY
FIVE AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
THEN SB EIGHT TWO EIGHT THIS
PAST YEAR ITS CITY WAS JUST SO
ON THE BALL.
IN TERMS OF GETTING THEM
IMPLEMENTED I KNOW WE EVERY
LEGISLATOR HAS A HORROR STORY
ABOUT PASSING A LAW AND THEN --
GET SIGNED THE LAW THEM FIVE
YEARS LATER IT'S NOT HAVE OF
AGENCY HAS IMPLEMENTED IT BUT
IT'S IT IS REALLY ON TOP OF IT
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY SOMEONE.
IT AFTERNOON.
SO I WORK FOR THE PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW PROJECT WHICH IS A
STATE WIDE SUPPORT CENTER --
PROVIDING TRAINING AND EXPERTISE
TO LOCAL LEGAL AID PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN AREAS OF
HOUSING LAND USE AND PUBLIC
BENEFITS.
AND MY TRAINING FOR THIS JOB WAS
I SPENT FOURTEEN YEARS IN A
LOCAL LEGAL AID PROGRAM WHERE
MOST OF THE FOCUS OF MY WORK WAS
ON HOUSING AND LAND USE.
MEETING THE NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE
WHO WATCH IN OUR DOOR EVERY DAY
WHO ARE A CONSTANT REMINDER OF
THE IMPACT OF NOT HAVING STABLE
SAFE HOUSE.
RIGHT ALL OF THE EMPLOYMENT
NECESSARY NOT OUT COMES IN
RESPONSE TO THAT --
WHAT I WANTED TO VOTE FOCUS ON
TODAY OR THREE PRIMARY AREAS
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE CHANGES TO
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW AND KIND OF
THE RESPONSES TO THAT THE
BENEFITS RIGHT IN TERMS OF
INCREASING COMPLIANCE AND ALSO?
I JUST INCREASING COMPLIANCE
WITH THE LAW BUT THAT RESULTING
IN BETTER PLANNING AND ZONING
AND PRODUCTION OF HOUSING --
GOING BACK TO CHANGES THAT WERE
MADE PRIOR TO THE FIFTH CYCLE
THAT MEGAN REFERRED TO ALSO SOME
CHANGES THAT WERE PART OF THE
ENORMOUS HOUSING PACKAGE INTO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT'S EARLY NOW
IN THE PLANNING STAGES TO SEE
SOME OF THOSE RESPONSES --
BUT I CAN TELL YOU ANECDOTALLY
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'VE SEEN SO FAR
AND THEN LASTLY JUST TO FOCUS ON
SOME FUTURE CHANGES TO HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW --
HOPEFULLY AS SENATOR POINTED OUT
HOUSING ELEMENTS DON'T HOUSE
PEOPLE HOMES DO BUT AS WE RAISE
THE BAR FOR WHAT HOUSING ON IT'S
REQUIRED THAT IS MORE LIKELY TO
RESULT IN HOMES THAT IT WAS
MAYBE TEN YEARSAGO --
SO FIRST TO POINT OUT SOME OF
THE CHANGES THAT HAPPENED AT THE
START OF THE FIFTH --
PLANNING PERIOD IN THOSE YOU
KNOW WE NOW HAVE HAD EIGHT YEARS
AND SOME OF THESE JURISDICTIONS
ARE ALMOST EIGHT YEARS TO SEE
HOW THOSE CHANGES HAVE IMPACTED
AS A MOSTLY UP POSITIVELY --
SOIN ADDITION TO CHANGING
HOUSING ELEMENTS TO AN EIGHT
YEAR PLANNING PERIOD THERE WERE
SOME OTHER SIGNIFICANT CHANGES --
ONE WAS TO IMPOSE A PENALTY FOR
LACK OF A BETTER WORD AND CITIES
AND COUNTIES THAT DID NOT TIMELY
ADOPT THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT.
SO THAT IF THEY WENT BEYOND A
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS FROM THEIR
STATUTORY DUE DATE --
THEY HAD TO DO TO HOUSING TO
ESTABLISH A FIRM DEADLINE FOR
ANY REZONING THAT WAS REQUIRED
IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE ADEQUATE
SITES IN YOUR INVENTORY AND YOU
NEEDED TO REZONE FOR THAT
SHORTFALL YOU HAD TO DO SO
WITHIN THREE YEARS --
AND LASTLY IDENTIFYING ZONES
WHERE EMERGENCY SHELTERS COULD
BE LOCATED --
WITHOUT DISCRETIONARY REVIEW.
SO I WOULD SAY THE OUTCOMES TO
THOSE THREE PRIMARY CHANGES WERE
MOSTLY POSITIVE --
SOME OF THEM WERE NOT AS MUCH.
OF I WOULD SAY IN THE AREA OF
THE DUE DATE --
WITHIN A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS OF
YOUR STATUTORY DEADLINE HAS
CAUSED SOME CONFUSION IT OFTEN
BECAME FROM THE AT BAT BECAUSE
PERSPECTIVE THAT THE NEW
DEADLINE WAS THE HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS AFTER THE STATUTORY DUE
DATE RIGHT NO LONGER DO WE PAY
ATTENTION TO NECESSARILY.
THE DUE DATE THAT IS IN THE
STATUTE BUT NOW THE ONLY ONE
THAT MATTERS AS A HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS OUT WHICH MEANS THAT YOU'RE
NOT NECESSARILY GETTING TIMELY
ADOPTION AND OFF IN
JURISDICTIONS REFER TO THIS AS
THE GRACE PERIOD --
IT WASN'T INTENDED THIS IS A TO
BE SO BUT THAT'S HOW IT WAS
REFERRED --
TO THE OTHER COMPONENT OF THAT
IS THAT.
THE STATUTORY DUE DATE REQUIRED
YOU TO ADOPT A HOUSING ELEMENT
WITHIN A HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS BUT
NOT A LEGALLY SUFFICIENT HOUSING
ELEMENT AT THAT TIME.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS JURISDICTIONS
ADOPT A HOUSING ELEMENT AND THEN
RECEIVE A LETTER FINING FROM A
CD THAT IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY
COMPLY WITH THE LAW AND THEN IT
MIGHT TAKE ONE YEAR SIX MONTHS
TWO YEARS FOR THEM TO REVISE
THAT HOUSING ELEMENT. TO COME
INTO COMPLIANCE SO TIMELY
ADOPTION DOESN'T NECESSARILY
TRANSLATE INTO TIMELY ADOPTION
OF A LEGALLY SUFFICIENT HOUSING
ELEMENT --
THE OTHER FACTOR THAT REMAINS --
AT I THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED SOMETIME IN THE FUTURE
IS THE IDEA OF THE FOUR YEAR
ELEMENT AS RESULT OF NOT
ADOPTING A HOUSING ELEMENT IN A
TIMELY WAY --
AND THAT'S BECAUSE I I I AND NOT
IN THE MINDSET OF THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN THE ADOPTED
THAT PENALTY BUT THE ASSUMPTION
PROBABLY WAS THAT MOST PEOPLE
WOULD BE WITH IT MOST
JURISDICTIONS WOULD BE WITHIN A
FEW MONTHS OF THAT.
DEADLINE.
SOMETIMES JURISDICTIONS ARE TWO
THREE IN ADOPTING THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT AND SO THE IDEA OF
ADOPTING A FOUR YEAR CYCLE THAT
BECOMES CONFUSING BECAUSE ARE
YOU REQUIRED TO UPDATE WITHIN
SIX MONTHS OF JUST ADOPTING
YOU'RE.
VERY VERY LATE HOUSING ELEMENT --
OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE TECHNICAL
ISSUES BUT THEY DO NEED TO BE
RESOLVED TO GET THE BEST AND
MOST LEGALLY SUFFICIENT HOUSING
ELEMENTS THAT WE CAN.
I WOULD SAY A VERY POSITIVE --
RESPONSE HAS BEEN TO THE
DEADLINE OF HAVING TO RESIGN
WITHIN THREE YEARS --
PREVIOUSLY ON THE FIVE YEAR
PLANNING PERIOD WITHOUT A
REQUIREMENT FOR WHEN THE RESUMES
HAD TO OCCUR SOMETIMES
JURISDICTIONS WERE WAITING FOR
THE VERY END OF THE PLANNING.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
MEET YOUR HOUSING NEED FOR THAT
PLANNING PUREED IF YOU'RE
WAITING TO THE VERY LAST MINUTE
TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE THE ZONING
SO HAVING AN UP FRONT DEADLINE
THREE YEARS INTO THE PROCESS
WHEN YOU STILL HAVE SEVERAL
YEARS AGO.
IT'S BEEN A VERY POSITIVE CHANGE
AND HAS RESULTED IN A LOT OF
REZONING IS HAPPENING MUCH
EARLIER IN THE PLANNING PROCESS
THAN EVER BEFORE --
AND THE LAST OF CHANGE THAT I
REFERRED TO IS DESIGNATING SITES
FOR EMERGENCY SHELTERS --
THAT DO NOT REQUIRE
DISCRETIONARY REVIEW AND I WOULD
SAY THERE THE THE RESPONSE HAS
ALSO BEEN POSITIVE IN TERMS OF
THE NUMBER OF JURISDICTIONS WHO
COMPLIED WITH THAT REQUIREMENT --
ONE AREA THAT WE TEND TO FOCUS
ON IS AT HOUSING ADVOCATES IS
THE CAPACITY OF THOSE SITES THE
NOT JUST IDENTIFYING A ZONE
WHERE SHELTERS ARE PERMITTED BUT
THAT THERE IS ACTUALLY CAPACITY
IN THOSE SITES FOR SHELTERS TO
BE DEVELOPED AND THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY.
SOME PROXIMITY TO TRANSIT IN
OTHER NEEDS THAT SHELTER --
RESIDENTS WOULD HAVE.
IN TERMS OF THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
CHANGES AS I MENTIONED IT'S
EARLY IN THE PROCESS THERE SOME.
COMMUNITIES AS HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED THAT ARE VERY LATE IN
THEIR PROCESS AND IN ADOPTING
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT AND THEY
ARE SUBJECT TO THE CHANGES FROM
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN PACKAGE --
AN OVER ALL I WOULD SAY THAT THE
THE THE MORE RIGID REQUIREMENTS
IN TERMS OF USING NON BACON
SITES IN TERMS OF HAVING TO
MONITOR YOUR LOSS OF UNITS TO
THE NET CHANGES TO THE NO NET
LOSS.
OF LAW HAVE BEEN VERY POSITIVE
IN TERMS OF ACTUALLY HAVING
SUITABLE FEASIBLE SO.
SO YOU FOR FOR A LONG TIME
JURISDICTIONS COULD IDENTIFY NON
VACANT SITES AS PART OF THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT INVENTORY.
BUT HAVING TO SHOW THAT THE
EXISTING USES REALLY ARE NOT
GOING TO INTERFERE OR IMPEDE
WITH POTENTIAL RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT HAS BEEN.
VERY USEFUL IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE THOSE SITES REALLY ARE
FEASIBLE AND WILL PROBABLY
DEVELOP WITHIN THE PLANNING
PERIOD --
THE LAST POINT I WANTED TO MAKE
IS ABOUT FUTURE CHANGES AND SO.
PROBABLY THE CHANGES TO NO NET
LOSS COME CLOSEST --
TO IDENTIFYING THE REAL ISSUE
THAT THAT THAT MAY BE LACKING
BETWEEN THE PLANNING FOR HOUSING
AND THE ACTUAL PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING WHICH IS THAT WE RELIED
ON A LONG TIME FOR DENSITY AS A
PROXY FOR AFFORDABILITY.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE DO IN TERMS
OF THE HOUSING ELEMENT INVENTORY --
AND NO NET LOSS CHANGES HAVE
BEEN THE CLOSEST TO KIND OF
IDENTIFYING THE IDEA THAT IF YOU
IDENTIFY A SITE IN YOUR HOUSING
ELEMENT. TO MEET THE NEEDS OF A
SPECIFIC INCOME GROUP.
AND THAT SITE IS DEVELOPED FOR
DOT FOR A DIFFERENT INCOME GROUP
THAT YOU HAVE TO REPLACE IT SO
IDENTIFYING THAT THE SITE IS NOT
JUST ABOUT DENSITY BUT ACTUALLY
BEING AVAILABLE FOR THAT INCOME
LEVEL.
OTHER CHANGES ARE PROBABLY
NECESSARY LOOSE CHANGE WAS MADE.
PART OF LEGISLATIVE CHANGE YES
THAT'S I THAT'S WHAT I WOULD SAY
THAT THAT HIS GOD IF YOU KNOW
THAT'S A VERY USEFUL STEP
TOWARDS KIND OF AVOIDING DENSITY
AS THE PROP THE ONLY PROXY FOR
AFFORDABILITY.
INSTEAD OF A REQUIREMENT FOR
AFFORDABILITY WHETHER THAT COMES
FROM A REQUIREMENT WHETHER IT
COMES FROM INCENTIVES THAT'S FOR
THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM TO
DECIDE.
BUT NEEDING MORE THAN JUST THE
IDEA THAT DENSITY ALONE IS GOING
TO RESULT IN AFFORDABILITY
ESPECIALLY IN MOST OF THE LARGER
HOUSING MARKETS IN OUR STATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR MY CHANCE
TO SUBMIT THESE COMMENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ACCORDING TO THEIR
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THIS PANEL --
YES SENATOR MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M.
STILL TRYING TO GET MY ARMS
AROUND RENO AFTER.
ALL THESE YEARS AND SO I HAVE
FOUR CITIES.
THERE JAY SENT THE BORDER EACH
OTHER. ONE HAS TO READ READ A
REQUIREMENT OF FIVE ANOTHER ONE
TOO BUT WE'RE GETTING RID OF
THAT THAT'S GOING TO GO AWAY.
ANOTHER ONE IS.
EIGHTY SIX WE ARE THE FIRST TO A
POPULATIONS OF A HUNDRED
THOUSAND SOME ODD. EIGHTY SIXES
GOT.
EIGHTY THOUSAND AND IN A CITY OF
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND WHICH HAS
ARENA REQUIREMENT OF ABOUT. ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THREE WHICH YEAH.
AND AND AND THEIR SHORT FOUR
HUNDRED I MEAN THEY'RE WORKING
ON IT.
BUT IT SAID CITY HUNTINGTON
BEACH I GOT.
TO AND I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
WHY IS A CITY THAT'S TRYING TO
PRODUCE THIRTEEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE UNITS FROM THE NEIGHBOR?
NEXT DOOR ONLY HAS TO PRODUCE.
TO IS NOW THE CENTER OF ALL THE
NEWS AND ALL THE FUN AROUND HERE
SO HELP ME OUT CAN YOU.
HOW DO I EXPLAIN THIS TO MY
CONSTITUENTS?
I SO YES THE THE THE FIFTH CYCLE
AND THE LAST CYCLE WE CAME UP ON
AS THE NUMBERS YOU'RE REFERRING
TO SO THOSE ARE THE NUMBERS THAT
JURISDICTION'S HAVE RIGHT NOW.
AND A COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENT ON
EVERYTHING OTHER THAN THE BOLD
ON THIS THE COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENT --
FOR THAT REGION SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO WAS LEGALLY
REQUIRED TO CONSIDER ALL OF
THESE FACTORS IN HOW THEY TOOK
THE REGIONAL NUMBER THAT EACH
CITY PROVIDED.
IN ALLOCATING TO THEIR
JURISDICTIONS --
BUT THERE WASN'T A LOT OF
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT WHAT THEY HAD
TO DO OTHER THAN CONSIDER THAT
SO COMING UP IN THE NEXT CYCLE
THEY WILL BE REQUIRED TO SPELL
OUT.
HOW ALL NUMBERS WERE GIVEN OUT
ACCORDING TO A METHODOLOGY
INCLUDING?
MAKE IT CLEAR HOW EACH OF THE
FACTORS ON THIS LIST WAS USED --
AND AC WILL HAVE A REVIEW WITH
ALREADY THERE THAT WASN'T
PRESENT IN THE PRIOR CYCLE AND
SO THERE IS NO WAY TO TRACE BACK
THE LINEAGE OF HOW.
A FIVE VERSES AT TEN THOUSAND
WAS DECIDED --
SO THAT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WILL CHANGE GOING FORWARD BUT
WAS NOT PRESENT IN THE LAST
CYCLE -- AND
THEN I I I THINK DOES THAT
ADDRESS PART OF THAT'S GOOD THAT
HELPS BECAUSE YOU KNOW I'M
SITTING HERE GOING I AM NOT.
I'M NOT DOING THE MATH IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT WORKING OUT FOR ME SO I
JUST THOUGHT IT WOULD BRING IT
UP ST JUDE MENTIONED.
THE CITY AT THE LAST PANEL AND
AND AND JUST.
YOU KNOW FOR MAYBE.
EQUAL TIME MR.
I PRESENT MY MAJOR SORRY CENTER
NUMBER GETS IN HERE HE THE ALSO
THE OTHERS THAT CITY WITH ME AND
IF I JUST MAY --
TO PIGGY BACK ON THAT I THINK --
I THINK THIS HERB IS A 100%
RIGHT THAT THE BILLS THAT WE
PASSED IN --
WE WE'VE DONE OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS A WHOLE SERIES OF BILLS
FROM BOTH HOUSES. TO REALLY
TIGHTEN UP THE HOUSING ELEMENT
LAW STOP SOME OF THE AVOIDANCE
TECHNIQUES THAT HAVE BEEN USE
LIKE SAY --
WE'RE GONNA PUT OUR LOW INCOME
HOUSING ON THIS SITE WE KNOW
THAT A TARGET WITH SINCE BUILT
THERE TWO YEARS AGO SO IT'S NOT
GONNA BE AVAILABLE FIFTY YEARS
WITHOUT TO RE DOING.
A LOW INCOME HOUSING TO REALLY
CUT DOWN. TO RENO.
RENO IS SO POLITICIZED AND YOU
KNOW AT AT THE REGION GETS ITS
AGGREGATE NUMBER AND THAT IT'S A
FOOD FIGHT.
ABOUT WHAT THE ALLOCATIONS ARE
TEACH CITY AND SO WEALTHIER
CITIES TEND TO BE ABLE TO PUSH%
DOWN THEIR NUMBERS --
AND YOU HAVE SOME OF THESE
OUTRAGEOUS DISPARITIES CITING
WE'RE GOING TO SEE A REDUCTION
AND AND THAT KIND OF APPROACH I
THINK THAT'S FAIR MISTER BECAUSE
I'M FINDING THAT CITIES ARE
DOING THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT.
AND THEN THEY DON'T MEET HIM.
AND I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
PENALTIES SHOW UP OR WHAT
HAPPENED I I HAVE BEEN
FRUSTRATED WITH SB TWO ZONES.
SO I'VE GOT CITIES THAT FINALLY
FIGURE OUT WHERE THEY SHOULD PUT
A HOMELESS SHELTER.
AND THEN I GO.
WITH MY COLLEAGUES ON THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND I BY A
COMMERCIAL BUILDING IN THAT SB
TO ZONE FOR TWO HUNDRED BED.
HOMELESS SHELTER ONLY BE TOLD BY
THE CITY NO WAY YOU'RE NOT GONNA
PUT.
A SHELTER THERE AND I'M GOING
THIS IS YOUR SB TUZLA.
SO NOW I HAVE TO BACK OUT OF
ESCROW I HAD THAT TWICE SO I'M
SITTING HERE SAYING WE GET ALL
THESE GREAT LAWS AND ALL THESE
REQUIREMENTS.
BUT THEY'RE JUST PAYING LIP
SERVICE [inaudible]
WHAT?
AND CAN I ASK OKAY THAT'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT THE ABOUT THE
SHELTERS IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE
YOU MENTIONED SB.
TWO IN THE LAST PANEL AND I YOU
KNOW.
WORK YEAH SB T. S. GIVE ME --
SB.
BRAVO SIX WITH SIDE ARMS
PROPOSITION TWO RIGHT.
YOU'RE TRYING TO GET.
YOU KNOW.
FACILITIES FOR MILLIE ILL
HOMELESS PEOPLE SO I'M I'M
WORKING ON IT BUT I'M.
KIND OF SHARING SOME OF YOUR
FRUSTRATIONS BUT HOW DO WE HOW
DO WE MAKE EVERYTHING FAIR
EQUITABLE UNDERSTANDABLE.
AND THEN HOW DO WE HAVE A GOOD
RELIABLE FOLLOW THROUGH AND I
JUST I JUST NEEDED TO GET THAT
OFF MY CHEST MISTER CHAIR THING
NO CENTER MORE AYE AYE.
AYE INTEGRATE POINT I'VE
QUESTION FOR MISS --
FELDMAN --
IS -- WERE
YOU MEANT HAVE SITES FOR
HOMELESS.
SHELTER.
AND SO THE QUESTION IS.
HOW IS THAT GOING --
AND WE DO HAVE A LIVE ALL THREE
BILL THIS YEAR SB FORTY EIGHT AT
TEN TEN BILL NOW BUT IT'S GOING.
TO IT'S DESIGNED TO ACHIEVE
BETTER GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY --
FOR HOMELESS NAVIGATION CENTERS
SHELTERS ETCETERA BECAUSE WE
HAVE ENTIRE COUNTIES NOW WITH
ZERO SHELTER BEDS.
COUNTIES THAT ONLY HAVE SHELTER
BEDS IN THE WINTER OR HAVE VERY
FEW OR DON'T HAVE RUNNING WATER
NOTHING FOR YOUTH AND SO ON SO
HOW IS THAT GOING TO THANK.
STATE JUST AS I SAID THAT.
HOUSING ELEMENT.
MATTERS IF THE HOUSING ELEMENT
BARS RAISED SO JUST AS WE HAS
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
SITES FOR FOR ZONING FOR THAT
SINGLE FAMILY MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING.
ZONING FOR SHELTERS COULD ALSO
YOU SO THE INITIAL IT'LL PHASE
IS I DID JONES WERE SHOCKED
WITHOUT DISCRETIONARY REVIEW.
BUT THEN WHEN YOU SEE WHERE
THOSE SITES ARE LOCATED OR WHERE
THERE IS OWNS ARE LOCATED
SOMETIMES THAT IS NOT IN TERMS
OF WHAT AVAILABLE FUNDING MIGHT
BE.
WHAT IN TERMS OF WHAT ACCESS
THERE MIGHT BE AN AMENITIES THEY
MAY NOT BE THE BEST SITES?
FOR SHELTERS ALSO THERE MIGHT
NOT REALLY BE CAPACITY WITHIN
THOSE ZONES FOR SHELTERS THAT
COULD REALLY MEET THAT NEED.
SO I GUESS WHAT I'M TRYING TO
SAY IS IN THE SAME WAY THAT THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN PACKAGE REALLY
TIGHTENED UP.
THE ADEQUACY OF THE SITES
REQUIREMENTS AND NOT RE USING
SITES OVER AND OVER AND SOME OF
THE OTHER CHANGES.
ZONES THAT PERMIT EMERGENCY
SHELTERS WITHOUT DISCRETIONARY
REVIEW PROBABLY COULD BENEFIT
FROM SOME OF THOSE SAME
REQUIREMENTS IN TERMS OF LOOKING
AT WHAT AMENITIES ARE LOCATED
CLOSE TO THOSE ZONES --
AND WHETHER OR NOT THOSE ARE
USUALLY HAVE THE CAPACITY FOR
THE SHELTERS THAT THEY'RE BEING
IDENTIFIED SUB.
AS YOU AS YOU ALLUDED TO IN
HOUSING ELEMENT AS THEY WERE
OFTEN THE IDEA THAT YOU KNOW A
SITE WITH THE WITH THE WITH THE
CURRENT USE HAD SOME
REDEVELOPMENT POTENTIAL OR AND
THAT STILL OCCURS AND SB TWO
SITES ARE THE SITES THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED FOR EMERGENCY
SHELTERS WHERE.
YES MAYBE THERE'S A CURRENT USE
THERE BUT IT'S IT'S NOT THAT
THAT USES INCOMPATIBLE WITH
EMERGENCY SHELTERS SO WILL OKAY
IT -- AND SO
TIGHTENING THOSE REQUIREMENTS
PROBABLY WOULD BE MORE USEFUL
ESPECIALLY NOW IF THERE IS SOME
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO BUILD THOSE
SHELTERS.
WITH UP TO HAVE A FURTHER
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ABOUT THAT
THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS CALL YES CENTER
NIELSEN CENTER BELT.
QUICKLY WAS FELDMAN.
THERE SEEM TO BE A KIND OF A I
DON'T KNOW IF I WOULD CALL IT A
IN EQUITY OR CHEAP SHOT AWHILE
BACK.
A VERY MINUSCULE CITY IN THE
AREA THAT I REPRESENT WAS
SINGLED OUT NOT MEETING THEIR
REQUIREMENTS.
IT'S  RURAL COUNTY IT'S A VERY
IN COBB WRIST AREA.
THE CITY HAS VERY LIMITED
RESOURCES.
AND THEY'RE DOING.
BUT TRYING.
TO BEAT THE GAME.
A VERY WEALTHY COUNTY.
IN THE BUDGET SLIPPED IN A
PROVISION EXTENDING THEIR
ELEMENT MANY YEARS.
SEEMS LIKE THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
OBJECT TO THAT.
THAT KIND OF A THAT CERTAINLY IS
NOT EQUITABLE.
AND THEN LET A A VERY WEALTHY
COUNTY JUST EXTENDED FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME THERE MAY BE SOME
VERY LEGITIMATE CIRCUMSTANCES
BUT WHEN I HEARD AND BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
THAT WAS NOT CONVINCING DOES
THAT HAPPEN A LOT.
I MIGHT FROM MY EXPERIENCE IT
DOES NOT NESTLE HAPPEN A LOT BUT
THE IDEA OF KIND OF STRONGER
JURISDICTIONS PUSHING SOME OF
THE RENO REQUIREMENT ON SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS KIND OF TRADING
BETWEEN THAT RENO ALLOCATION.
YOU CAN SEE HOW THAT INFLUENCE
WOULD HAPPEN RIGHT SO THAT IF A
STRONGER JURISDICTION IS SAYING.
ARMENIA ALLOCATION IS THIS
NUMBER AND WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE IT IF SOME OF THE
SMALLER JURISDICTIONS WOULD TAKE
ON SOME OF THAT REQUIREMENT THAT
KIND OF TRADING HAS OCCURRED.
AND IN OF A JURISDICTION DOESN'T
HAVE RESOURCES FOR THE PLANNING
STAFF AND OTHER PEOPLE WHO MIGHT
BE NEEDED TO DEVELOP A HOUSING
ELEMENT TO MEET THAT NEED.
YOU KNOW THAT CREATES A HEAVIER
BURDEN ON THEM BUT DAYS NOT
NECESSARILY.
IN DETERMINING WHAT THE OVERALL
HOUSING NEED NUMBERS ARE YOU AND
I WOULD ARGUE THAT SUCH.
KIND OF REAL FOUNDED POLICY
BECAUSE IT THE IT DOES NOT MAKE
SENSE OF THE SMALLER ENTITY DOES
NOT HAVE THE MEANS TO RESOURCES
AND WHATEVER THEY COULD TRADE.
TO ADD TO THE ABILITY OF THE
RELIEF TO A LARGER MORE WEALTHY
COUNTY IT.
IT'S BEEN INFINITESIMAL THE YES
AND AND THIS IS NOT TO SAY THAT
THAT THAT PROBLEM WILL BE
COMPLETELY ELIMINATED BUT AT
LEAST A REGION --
PERFORMING AS ALLOCATION FOR
THIS NEXT CYCLE WOULD HAVE O
DOCUMENT HOW THOSE NUMBERS DOT
THERE SO AND YOU KNOW IT IF IT'S
GOING TO BE POLITICAL.
DECISION MAKING LIKE THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE.
TO SPELL IT OUT AND SHOW HOW
THAT WAS AND YOU HAVE TO SHOW
COSTS THE DOCTOR CHAU BECAUSE
NOW TO SHOW THAT IT WAS STILL IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THOSE STATUTORY
FACTORS I TALKED ABOUT.
AT THE BEGINNING THAT REALLY DO
INCLUDE ACT WITH EQUITY THANK
YOU THAT'S ENCOURAGING
[inaudible]
REQUIRE.
OUR CENTER BELL FROM START
CENTER BELL AND THEN SOME WATER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
THE QUESTION THE QUESTION I HAVE
ON THE RENO IS TO DATE TO DO A
US.
ARE -- DO
YOU COLLECT DATA ON THE SIZE OF
THE UNITS.
LIKE THE SQUARE FOOTAGE IS THAT
COLLECTED ANYWHERE [inaudible]
I'M.
THAT IS A GOOD QUESTION AND AT
THE HOUSING ELEMENT STAGE WHEN
IT'S A PLANNING REQUIREMENT --
YOU DO HAVE TO SHOW THE CAPACITY
OF THE LAND --
SO YOU.
YOU WOULD TO A CERTAIN DEGREE.
AND I KNOW THE SQUARE FOOTAGE
THAT WOULD BE INTENDED FOR THAT
SITE.
I THINK ON THE OTHER AND I NEED
TO CHECK IF THAT WAS ADDED.
RIGHT REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT BUT
BEDROOMS AYE I DO NOT BELIEVE
BEDROOMS WAS INCLUDED SQUARE
FOOTAGE JUST AFFORDABILITY AND
PRIMER OF UNIT RISE YEAH.
THERE'S NO BUT I I COULD BE
MISTAKEN NAY BUT WE HAVE QUITE A
FEW NEW REQUIRED NEW ADDITIONS
TO OUR REPORTING AND I CAN CHECK
TO SEE IF IT'S THERE BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE IT IS.
BECAUSE I THINK THE I THINK ONE
OF THE ISSUES FOR ME IS THE THE
CITY THAT HAS LOW DENSITY BUT
THEY BUILD.
LARGE SQUARE FOOTAGE.
HOUSING NO SINGLE FAMILY
[inaudible]
WHEREAS.
THEY'RE NOT INCLUDING IN THE
PLANNING OF A PROJECT
[inaudible]
SMALLER.
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS.
OR CONDOS OR WHATEVER YOU'RE
TRYING TO BUILD SO.
THERE'S NO WAY OF JUDGING
WHETHER OR NOT THE CITY CAN --
HAVE A LAND USE OF DECISION.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE SMALLER.
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS.
COMPARED TO BUILDING --
A BUNCH OF LARGER.
YOU KNOW THAT WHAT'S THE AVERAGE
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES BEING BUILT
NO.
SO A SERVICE WHAT IS IT. TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED SQUARE FEET --
MAN SOMEBODY'S GOT SOME NUMBER I
THREE THOUSAND SQUARE FEET
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED SQUARE FEET.
SO SO LIKE.
WHEN I WHEN I LOOK AT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING I DON'T SEE ANY? TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS I SEE.
THOSE ARE SMALLER HOUSING UNITS.
IT -- IF YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION IT'S
HARD. TO TO LOOK AT WHETHER OR
NOT SERVE THE COULD BE
AFFORDABLE IT MAY NOT FULLY
ADDRESS YOUR CONCERN BUT IN THAT
HOUSING ELEMENT REQUIREMENTS --
THEY ARE THIS JURISDICTION HAS%
THEIR RENA'S ACTUALLY FOUR
SEPARATE NUMBERS A VERY LOW
INCOME A LOW INCOME A MODERATE
AND ABOVE MODERATE GOAL.
THEY DO NEED TO SHOW US ZONING
FORCE.
SMALLER UNITS DENSER UNITS. TO
MEET THEIR LOWER INCOME SIDE OF
THEIR RECALL SO THAT THEY CAN'T
THEY CAN'T COUNT.
ON SINGLE FAMILY ZONING FOR A
FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT HOME
TOWARD THEIR VERY LOW.
WIENER CARMEN AT THE HOUSING
ELEMENT AT THE PLANNING STAGE.
SO HANNAH HANNAH DEVELOPER CAME
TALK TO ME ABOUT THE CD PLAYED.
FOR A DEVELOPMENT A SMALLER CITY
IN.
HE HAD --
PRESENTED THE CITY WITH. TWO
OPTIONS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE YOU KNOW KIND OF A SMALL
PIECE OF PROPERTY.
HE SAID --
ONE OF THE OPTIONS HAD TWO
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT --
TOWN HOMES.
THE WAS GONNA SELL FOR QUITE A
BIT OF MONEY.
THERE --
OPTION WOULD BE TO HAVE. TWO
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT TOWN HOMES
AND PART OF THE PROPERTY AND THE
OTHER PART.
HAVE -- ONE
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT TOWN HOMES.
IN OTHER WORDS HAVE A MIX OF
AFFORDABILITY AND HE WAS GOING
[inaudible]
TO HAVE THOSE. FOUR EIGHT A
LOWER AMOUNT HE HAD.
YEAH I THINK --
ACTUALLY A VERY SLIGHT INCREASE
IN THE TOTAL NUMBER OF UNITS BUT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE THE SQUARE
FOOTAGE.
IT WAS ACTUALLY LOWER.
SQUARE FOOTAGE.
WITH THE ONE THAT HAD THE MORE
UNITS THAN --
THE THE ONE I HAD ALL THE TWO
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT UNITS.
SO I THINK I THINK FOR ME FOR ME --
WHEN THEY SAY THEY CAN'T BUILD?
THEY HAVE TWO THOUSAND SQUARE
FOOT UNIT IS IT'S KIND OF A OKAY
YOU'RE NOT REALLY.
CREATING A YOU HAVE OPTIONS.
AND THE OPTIONS IS WHETHER OR
NOT YOU WANT TO MAKE A HIGHER
PROFIT IS WHAT I'VE.
THAT'S THE OPTION IS NOT ABOUT
SUBSIDIES ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT --
I CAN MAKE MORE MONEY IF I SO.
THE TWO THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
HOUSING UNIT.
BUT THERE'S NO REASON WHY THEY
COULD BILL THE OTHER OPTION THE
ONE WITH THE ONE THOUSAND SQUARE
FOOT OPTION THEY JUST WOULD MAKE
AS MUCH MONEY.
YOU KNOW SO I I THINK THAT'S A
FOR ME. FOR ME A AN ISSUE.
WITH THE RAIN AND THE RATE OUGHT
TO HAVE THE SQUARE FOOTAGE OF
THE OF THE HOUSING UNITS.
HOW HOW MANY HOW MANY UNITS WERE
BUILT WHAT SQUARE FOOTAGE
[inaudible]
AND HOW MUCH THE UNITS COSTS OF
COURSE THAT'S THE VALUE ISSUE.
THANK YOU AND THERE IS A A BILL
PENDING THIS YEAR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WORKS INTRODUCED THE COP
THE PERCENTAGE OF HOUSING
ELEMENT.
ELEMENT THAT CAN BE SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES SOME [inaudible]
THE I THINK WHAT'S GOING ON IN A
LOT OF THESE COMMUNITIES MISTER
CHAIRMAN IS THERE'S THERE'S A
LOT OF THESE VERY X. THEY'RE
TRYING TO BUILD VERY EXPENSIVE
CONDOS OKAY AS WHAT'S GOING ON
IN AT LEAST IN MY AREA.
THERE THERE HIGH DENSITY BUT
THERE.
VERY EXPENSIVE HIGH DENSITY
CONDOS MILLION DOLLAR CONDOS.
THERE TOWARD THAT ARE TWO
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT CONDO SUIT
VERY HIGH DENSITY.
AND I THINK I THINK WHEN THEY
HAVE THESE HIGH DENSITY PROJECTS
[inaudible]
OF THE CITY COULD INSTILL A RAN
A FACTOR. TO MEET THE GOALS OF
SIMPLY SAYING WE WANT TO MIX.
WE WHAT WE WATER MIX OF TYPES OF
UNITS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE SOME
AFFORDABILITY IN YOUR PROJECT
[inaudible]
AND THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT I HOPE WOULD
HAPPEN -- IN
THE PROCESS OF WITH ARENA RITA
IMPLEMENTATION.
I WOULD I WOULD SAY THE TWO
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT CONDOS
UNDERMINES DENSITY BECAUSE IT
MEANS THAT FEWER UNITS.
THANK THANK YOU CENTER SENATE
MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
I'LL BE VERY UICK --
I I DON'T EVER.
WANT TO SPEAK FOR THE
MINISTRATION BECAUSE I DON'T BUT
I DO BELIEVE SPECIAL SEND THOSE.
A JURISDICTION CITIES COUNTIES --
EIGHTY SEVEN THAT WERE NOT
MEETING THEIR GOALS I DO BELIEVE
THAT THE MINISTRATION.
IS TAKING AN APPROACH.
OPERATION WITH MANY OF THEM IT'S
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
BUT I'LL GIVE ME EXAMPLE ONLY
COUNTY.
WHO ARE NOWHERE NEAR HITTING
THEIR GOALS BECAUSE OF THE FIRES
IT'S AN OBVIOUS REASON?
THERE ARE OTHERS WHO ARE OUT
LIARS WHO SIMPLY DOES NOT WANTED
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE CANDIDLY --
BUT BY THE TWO EXAMPLES THAT I
CAN GIVE AT LEAST IN OUR NECK OF
THE WOODS WOULD BE LAKE COUNTY
AND RIO DEL IN RIO DELL IS A
SMALL --
COVERAGE COMMUNITY AND THEY'RE
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
JURISDICTIONS IF THEY CAN --
PROVE THEIR CASE AND I THINK
THAT -- THE
NUMBER SIR WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO LOOK
AT THANK YOU.
FOR CALLING FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
INFORMATIVE PANEL --
ON THE HANDLE TO CENTER MCGUIRE
FOR THE FINAL FINAL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR --
THIS IS BEEN A FANTASTIC HEARING
THIS FAR END WE'RE GRATEFUL TO
OUR NEXT PANELIST WHO WERE ME
BRING YOU WERE GONNA BE CMING
UP.
WE'RE GONNA BE FOCUSING ON
STRATEGIES TO FACILITATE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IN BIG CITIES AND
SMALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA AS THEY
COME UP WE'RE GONNA INTRODUCE
THEM.
EATEN L. KIND IS GONNA LEAD US
OFF HE CENTER FOR LAW ENERGY IN
THE ENVIRONMENT AT UC BERKELEY
SCHOOL OF LAW HE'S GONNA BE
FOCUSING ON THE BENEFITS OF
HOUSING NEAR TRANSIT.
WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT LEADS LOW
IS HERE SHE'S THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEVELOPMENT --
SERVICE DEPARTMENT IN SAN DIEGO.
SHE'S GONNA BE FOCUSING ON SAN
DIEGO'S EFFORTS TO STREAMLINE
HOUSING PRODUCTION IN LINKING
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING
WITHIN HAVE ROBERT HUGHES THE
PRESIDENT CEO OF ADOBE
COMMUNITIES.
FOCUSING ON THE NEED TO OPEN UP
THE LAND AND BUILD MORE
STRATEGICALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
DENSITY.
AND THEN WE HAVE ERIC PHILLIPS.
WHO IS AN ATTORNEY IN VICE
PRESIDENT POLICY AND LEGISLATION
AT AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION --
HE'S GONNA BE A SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSING ON CENTER BY CAL SKIS
FAVORITE ISSUE ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS --
CURRENT POLICIES EXAMPLES OF
PRACTICES.
AT THAT ENCOURAGE DEVELOPMENT
CAME CHALLENGES WE WELCOME OUR
FOUR PANELISTS --
TO THE DICE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE WE'RE GONNA ASK
THAT EACH PANELIST.
KEEPS WITHIN A FIVE MINUTE TIME
LIMIT IT WILL GIVE YOU A THIRTY
SECOND WARNING AS WE GET CLOSE
TO THE FIVE MINUTES LET'S START
OFF WITH MR AL KIND AND WE
WELCOME YOU SIR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US TODAY OKAY
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
TALK ABOUT THE CLIMATE IMPACTS
OF I THE CLIMATE PROGRAM ENERGY
IN THE IN UC BERKELEY LAWCENTER
SKINNER IS ACTUALLY A ADVISORY
BOARD MEMBER SO WE THANK HER FOR
HER.
SERVICE ON OUR BOARD.
I'M A IN TERMS OF THE IMPACTS OF
DRIVING WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
OUR CLIMATE GOALS IN CALIFORNIA
IN THIS CHART SHOWS YOU WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE IN THE
STATE SO WE'RE TRYING.
TO ACHIEVE NINETEEN NINETY
LEVELS OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BY THE YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ACCORDING TO THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD WE ALREADY
ACHIEVED THAT GOAL FOUR YEARS
EARLY IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WHICH IS
GOOD NEWS.
BUT WE HAVE AN AGGRESSIVE GOAL
TO REDUCE THOSE EMISSIONS
FURTHER 40% BELOW NINETEEN
NINETY LEVELS BY THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY AND THEN 80% BELOW BY.
TWENTY FIFTY SO THESE ARE
AGGRESSIVE GOALS AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE CARBON FOOTPRINT IN
CALIFORNIA YOU CAN SEE FROM THIS
SIDE FROM THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD.
OVER 40%.
COME FROM TRANSPORTATION IF YOU
FACTOR IN OIL REFINERY EMISSIONS
IT'S CLOSER 250% THAT MEANS HALF
OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
IN CALIFORNIA ESSENTIALLY COME
FROM DRIVING.
WHEN OUR HAVE LAND USE PATTERNS
ARE A BIG FACTOR IN ALL THAT
DRIVING THAT WE DO NOT MANY
PEOPLE SAY WELL WE CAN SIMPLY
RELY ON ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES?
TO MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS WE
DON'T NEED TO CHANGE OUR LAND
USE PATTERNS AT ALL --
BUT THIS CHART HERE FROM THE
SCOPING PLAN SHOWS THAT WE STILL
NEED ABOUT 15%.
VMT VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
REDUCTIONS PER CAPITA --
BY THE YEAR TWENTY FIFTY EVEN IF
WE HAD A 100% ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE SALES AND THAT'S NOT
EVEN INCLUDING THE CARBON
BENEFITS OF HAVING MORE INFILL
FOCUSED DRIVING --
IN LAND USE PATTERNS BECAUSE AS
WE BUILD MORE IN OUR OPEN SPACE
FOR CARBON SEQUESTRATION
AGRICULTURAL LANDS FOR CARBON
SEQUESTRATION SO WE HAVE MANY
REASONS I SHOULD SAY EVEN IF YOU
DON'T CARE ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED SHOULD
MATTER TO YOU BECAUSE THIS IS
ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF TRAFFIC THAT
WE ALL HAVE TO SUFFER THROUGH
AND LOCALIZED AIR POLLUTION AND
OVERALL QUALITY OF LIFE.
SO WE'RE NOT DOING VERY WELL IN
THE SCORE IF YOU LOOK AT THIS
CHART OF VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
YOU CAN SEE THAT WE'VE BEEN
INCREASING SINCE THE GREAT
RECESSION WE'RE KIND OF BACK.
TO BUSINESS AS USUAL.
WE NEED TO FOCUS OUR DEVELOPMENT
PATTERNS AND OUR EXISTING
URBANIZED AREA THIS IS A CHART
FROM STUDY THAT WE DID OUR
CENTER ALONG WITH THE TURNER
CENTER AND HEARD FROM DAVID
GARCIA EARLIER.
THAT MODELED WHAT IT WOULD LOOK
LIKE IF WE BUILT TWO MILLION
HOMES APPROXIMATELY TWO MILLION
HOMES THROUGH TWENTY THIRTY
WHICH IS WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WAS TELLING US WE NEEDED
TO BUILD.
WHAT IF WE FOCUSED ALL THAT
GROWTH IN LOW VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED AREAS?
OR AREAS THAT WERE THREE MILE
RADIUS FROM AIL STATION SO
THAT'S WHAT THIS MAP SHOWS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THIS IS 4% OF
THE STATE'S LAND AREA WHERE WE
CAN ACCOMMODATE.
THESE TWO MILLION NEW UNITS THE
AND WE'RE PRETTY MODERATE
ASSUMPTIONS RUSSIAN SAID THIS IS
ALL ABOUT HIGHRISES THIS WAS A
MIX OF SINGLE FAMILY AND MULTI
FAMILY.
BUT CERTAINLY GO BACK A SLIGHT
HERE THIS IS A ZOOMED IN VIEW
HERE JUST TO SEE WHAT LOOKS LIKE
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA WE
FOUND THAT IF YOU BUILT.
OUR HOMES IN THESE AREAS THESE
URBANIZED AREAS NEAR TRANSIT WE
COULD REDUCE OUR CARBON
EMISSIONS BY ALMOST TWO MILLION
METRIC TONS EQUIPMENT TO TAKING
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND VEHICLES
OFF THE ROAD EVERY YEAR AND THIS
IS JUST FROM NEW RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT THIS DOESN'T INCLUDE.
IF WE PUT OFFICE DEVELOPMENT AND
THE BENEFITS TO EXISTING
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS FROM
HAVING MORE AMENITIES CLOSER AND
IT ALSO PRODUCE HIGHER ECONOMIC
GROWTH AND LOWER TRANSPORTATION
HOUSING COSTS SO A LOT OF
REASONS NOT TO WANT TO BUILD IN
THESE COMMUNITIES EVE IN THESE
AREAS EVEN IF YOU.
DIDN'T CARE AGAIN ABOUT ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE SO IN TERMS OF
HOW WE GET TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
IN THESE AREAS I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT THREE SPECIFIC POLICIES
THAT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON FROM A
STATE PERSPECTIVE.
BECAUSE WE SEE HOSTILITY TO NEW
HOUSING GROWTH IN MANY OF THESE
AREAS AND IT'S MOSTLY THE FORM
OF ZONING WHICH WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER BUT MANY COMMUNITIES
HIGHLY RESTRICTIVE.
LOCAL ZONING POLICIES WHICH ARE.
BUT MANY PEOPLE MOVE TO EXPAND
ESPECIALLY THE HIGHER INCOME
COMMUNITIES NOT REALLY WANTING
THE NEIGHBORHOOD TO CHANGE NOT
EXPECTING MORE GROWTH AND
THEY'RE VERY ADAMANT ABOUT
ALLOWING NEWCOMERS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF WHAT THEY HAVE IN
THESE COMMUNITIES.
SO I WOULD COMMEND SENATOR
WIENER FOR SB FIFTY WHICH IS A
FOLLOW UP TO SB EIGHT TWENTY
SEVEN FROM LAST YEAR WHICH I
THINK IS THE RIGHT TYPE OF
APPROACH.
WHERE WE NEED TO ESSENTIALLY
OVERRIDE LOCAL RESTRICTIONS ON
HOUSING PARTICULARLY AROUND
TRANSIT NOTES?
AND I I WOULD JUST POINT OUT
THAT THE TERMS OF THE DAMAGE
THAT SINGLE FAMILY.
ZONING HAS DONE IF YOU LOOK AT
LOS ANGELES TWO THIRDS OF LOS
ANGELES IS ZONED SINGLE FAMILY
HOUSING BACK IN NINETEEN THIRTY
THREE THAT WAS ONLY 5%.
AND I WOULD BET YOU MOST OF THE
GREATEST NEIGHBORHOODS IN LOS
ANGELES ARE PROBABLY IN THOSE
AREAS THAT WERE BUILT BEFORE.
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE POLICE
LAID OUT BEFORE.
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE I ALSO
THINK WE NEED TO RELAX THE
PERMITTING PROCESS --
IN TERMS OF GETTING THESE OF
THESE HOMES APPROVED THROUGH THE
PROCESS SEES AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SET UP YOU HEAR A LOT
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT BEING
A BARRIER. TO NEW HOUSING WILL A
LOT ABOUT A SELF INFLICTED A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THEY ADD IN SO
MANY DISCRETIONARY REVIEW
PROCESS SEES.
AND MY COLLEAGUE --
PROFESSOR BIEBER A BERKELEY LAW
HAS COME OUT WITH SOME SOME
STUDIES ON THIS WHICH WOULD BE
HAPPY TO SHARE AND BECAUSE THEY
HAD AN ALL THIS DISCRETION.
THAT TRIGGER SEQUENCE THAT THESE
ARE MINISTERIAL I ALSO COMMEND
SENATOR SKINNER FOR SB --
THREE THIRTY WHICH INTRODUCED
WHICH HELPS TO IT --
BASICALLY PUT  CAP ON THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT IT WOULD
PASS THE NUMBER OF HEARINGS THAT
WOULD BE IN PLACE FOR THESE
LOCAL APPROVALS BECAUSE THAT
ALSO MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE IT'S
THE ZONING BUT THEN IT'S ALSO
THE APPROVAL PROCESS SEES.
AND THEN JUST LASTLY I WOULD
POINT OUT THE NEED FOR A
FINANCING ASSISTANCE NOT ALL OF
THESE AREAS ARE IN HIGH INCOME.
HIGH GROWTH HIGH JOB GROWTH
AREAS THERE IN COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE -- VERY
UNDERSERVED IN TERMS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THEY NEED A LOT
OF PUBLIC INVESTMENT TO ATTRACT
REAL ESTATE DEVELOPMENT TO THESE
AREAS SO THINKING ABOUT A
REDEVELOPMENT TWO POINT NO TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING.
THAT TYPE OF APPROACH WOULD BE --
WOULD BE HELPFUL BECAUSE QUITE
SIMPLY PUT.
SEC.
THIS TYPE OF BUSINESS AS USUAL
APPROACH TO CALIFORNIA WITH AUTO
ORIENTED HOUSING GROWTH AND
CLOGGED HIGHWAYS AND ROADWAYS IS
SIMPLY NOT SUSTAINABLE TO MEET
OUR LONG TERM CLIMATE GOALS OR
THE QUALITY OF LIFE THAT WE NEED
TO SEE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WHAT THAT'LL ALL CLOSE AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AFTER
THE PANELS OF HAD A CHANCE TO
PRESENT THANK YOU.
THINK SO MUCH EXTRA KIND YES WE
WILL BE TAKING QUESTIONS AS SOON
AS WE HAVE EACH OF OUR
PRESENTERS.
AT PRESENT TO US TODAY WERE NOW
WELCOME IS SLOW CITY SAN DIEGO
[inaudible]
HI FAY ACCORDING TO MR ELK IN
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IS DOING
ALL THE RIGHT THINGS AND I'M
HERE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THAT
TODAY.
I DIDN'T BRING A POWER POINT SO
YOU'RE JUST GONNA HAVE TO LISTEN
TO ME A LITTLE BIT TALK ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE DOING TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR SAN DIEGANS FIND
SOMEWHERE TO LIVE 50% OF SAN
DIEGANS CAN'T AFFORD THE HOME
THAT THEY LIVE IN.
THEY NEED A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS SALARY IN
ORDER TO AFFORD OUR MEDIAN HOME
PRICE OF FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO I AM SAN DIEGO HAS CAPITALIZE
ON THE CHANGES THAT THE STATE
LEGISLATURES IMPLEMENTED LAST
SEVERAL SESSIONS INCLUDING
PERMITTING OUR GRANNY FLATS
WHERE WE'VE SEEN APPLICATIONS GO
FROM NINETEEN TO OVER.
FOUR HUNDRED AS WELL AS
UTILIZING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DENSITY BONUS PROGRAMS.
SAN DIEGO'S FIRST IN LINE TO
HAVE AN UPDATED HOUSING ELEMENT
UNDER THE NEWLY REVISED ARENA
PROGRAM SAN DIEGO IS NOT SHYING
AWAY FROM MARINO GOALS AND WILL
BE AND IS WILLING TO LEAD THE
REGION.
IN ORDER TO FIND THE ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY NEEDED WE NEED TO SEE
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW UNITS
DEVELOPED IN THE NEXT FIFTEEN
YEARS TO KEEP PACE WITH OUR
DEMAND.
IS A VERY DAUNTING NUMBERS
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW OUR PERMITTING
FIVE THOUSAND UNITS ANNUALLY
WHAT ARE WE DOING ABOUT IT FIRST
AND FOREMOST THE MAYOR IS
CHANGING THE CULTURE OF THE CITY.
THE MARE FAULKNER RECENTLY
PROCLAIM SAN DIEGO AS THE NB
CITY YES IN MY BACKYARD AND IS
ANNOUNCING ADDITIONAL DENSITY
BONUS PROGRAMS IN THE FUTURE
WHILE THERE WILL ALWAYS BE EATEN
IN THE OPPOSITION TO INCREASE.
INCREASE GROWTH AND DENSITY THEY
NEED FOR THE SUPPLY IS CLEAR AND
SAN DIEGO IS CHANGING THE RULES
TO MAKE HOUSING EASIER TO BUILD.
WE'RE REMOVING ARE RESTRICTIVE
ZONING THROUGH A SERIES OF
COMMUNITY PLAN UPDATES WE HAVE
FIFTY TWO NEIGHBORHOOD COMMUNITY
PLANNING AREAS AND WE'VE UPDATED
TWELVE OF THESE PLANS SINCE THE
MAYOR TOOK OFFICE WITH EIGHT
MORE IN PROGRESS.
IN THESE UPDATES WE ADDED ZONING
CAPACITY FOR FORTY THOUSAND NEW
UNITS AND WE'RE ON PACE TO ADD A
TOTAL OF A HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW
UNITS THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
POTENTIAL 425250% MORE UNITS.
THROUGH THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DENSITY BONUS PROGRAM.
THROUGH THE PLAN UPDATES WE WILL
INCREASES OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MINISTERIAL BY RIGHT PROJECTS SO
TAKING AWAY THE DISCRETION
ALLOWING AT STAFF LEVEL DECISION
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IF YOU NEED TO
DO A REZONE.
IT TAKES TWO YEARS TO PROCESS A
COMMUNITY PLAN AMENDMENT SO HUGE
IMPLICATIONS FOR THESE
MINISTERIAL PROJECTS.
AND INLINE WITH ARE LEGALLY
BINDING CLIMATE ACTION PLAN
GOALS SAN DIEGO'S INCENTIVIZE
HOUSING IN OUR TRANSIT RIORITY
AREAS.
SO MOST RECENTLY YESTERDAY SAN
DIEGO CITY COUNCIL PASSED
SWEEPING PARKING REFORMS FOR NEW
DEVELOPMENT NEAR TRANSIT.
ELIMINATING ALL PARKING MINIMUM
CARLOS THEIR MAJOR TRANSIT STOPS
THE TRANSIT PRIORITY AREA COVERS
ALMOST HALF OF SAN DIEGO'S
DEVELOPER WILL LAND.
AND WAS STUDIED EXTENSIVELY FOR
PARKING USAGE 89% OF THE SITES
SURVEYED IN THE TRANSIT PRIORITY
AREA UNDER UTILIZED THOSE
PARKING SPACES.
THE NEW POLICY ALLOWS FOR ON
BUNDLING PARKING REQUIRES
DEVELOPERS TO PROVIDE MORE
TRANSPORTATION DEMAND MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES LIKE SUBSIDIZED
TRANSIT PASSES WE ALREADY REDUCE
THE PARKING RATIOS FOR
AFFORDABLE UNITS.
AND NOW WE'LL SEE MANY MORE
UNITS WERE PARKING SPACES IS NO
LONGER INCLUDED IN THE PRICE
GIVING SAN DIEGANS AND NEW
CHOICE TO BE CAR FREE.
WITH THE SECOND LARGEST CITY IN
CALIFORNIA I OVERSEE DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES WE ISSUE OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND PERMITS A YEAR WE'RE
CONSTANTLY REVIEWING OUR
BUSINESS PROCESS THESE AND TRY
TO FIND WAYS TO SHAVE TIME OFF
THE PROCESS.
INFILL DEVELOPMENT COMPLICATED
YOU GOT TO BE AN EXPERT TO GET
THROUGH THIS PROCES AND EVEN IF
YOU'RE BUILDING BY RIGHT YOU
STILL HAVE TO COME IN AND GET
MECHANICAL PLUMBING ELECTRICAL
FIRE SAFETY JOLLITY STORM WATER
TRANSPORTATION IMPACT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES.
KERR BETTER SIDEWALK FLOODING
FEMA PARKING BIKE LANES
LANDSCAPE HEIGHT SET BACK THAT'S
ALL YOUR MINISTERIAL PERMIT NO
WONDER IT TAKES SIX MONTHS --
BUT WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS MAKE
IT EASIER TO GET YOU THROUGH
THESE BASIC CODE REQUIREMENTS SO
ADMINISTRATIVELY WE CHANGED OUR
PROCESS TO BE LESS ITERATIVE.
LESS BACK AND FORTH WE ARE INPUT
INSTITUTING A NEW PROCESS WHERE
YOU WILL GO THROUGH ONE REVIEW
CYCLE AND COME BACK YOU WILL
BRING IN YOUR LICENSE ARCHITECTS
AND ENGINEERS AND WE WILL SIT AT
THE TABLE I WILL PROBLEM SOLVED
TO GET IT DONE THAT DAY.
IT'S CALLED OUR PERMIT NOW
PROGRAM I'M DOING IT FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS AND
I HOPE TO HAVE MORE OF THAT
HAPPENED WITHIN THE CITY.
RECENTLY THIS PROCESS SAVED AN
APPLICANT FOR MONTHS AND TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THE PERMIT.
FINALLY WE'RE EXCITED TO BE
MOVING INTO THIS CENTURY WITH
DIGITAL DST AND ELECTRONIC
PERMITTING AND WE THINK THAT
THAT'LL SAVE APPLICANTS TIME AND
MONEY IT'S NOT ON YEAH BUT WE'RE
MAKING IT HAPPEN.
SO PERMIT PROCESSING IS EASIER
WE'VE REDUCED THE NEED FOR
DISCRETIONARY REQUIREMENTS WE NO
LONGER REQUIRE PLANNING
COMMISSIONER CITY COUNCIL
APPROVAL FOR EVERY DEVIATION FOR
A SET BACK OR OR HIGH WE NOW
HAVE PUBLICLY NOTICE STAFF LEVEL
DECISIONS THAT ARE APPEALABLE TO
OUR PLANNING COMMISSION.
SAVING PROJECTS SIX MONTHS
DOLLARS WE ALSO EVEN CHANGE ALL
PROJECTS CAN BE APPEALED WE
RAISE THE APPEAL FEE TO A
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO BE COST
RECOVERABLE IN LINE WITH OTHER
CITIES.
AND WE MANDATED THAT APPEALS BE
DOCKET IT WITHIN THIRTY DAYS.
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS ARE --
AT FOR YOU IS THAT SAN DIEGO IS
COMPLETELY ON BOARD WITH THE
STATE'S GOALS FOR INCREASING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADDITIONAL
TOOLS ARE NEEDED FOR SAN DIEGO
TO IMPLEMENT STATE LEGISLATION
MORE QUICKLY. FOR BILLS WITH AN
OPT IN THE PROVIDED GREAT
GUIDING POLICY FRAMEWORK BUT IF
THE SECRET DOCUMENT HAS TO BE
COMPLETED BY A LOCAL AGENCY THAT
JUST ADDS ANOTHER YEAR TO OUR
PROCESS THIRTY SECONDS CITIES
IMPLEMENTING STATE LEGISLATION
NEEDS STREAMLINED ENVIRONMENTAL
PROCESS FROM THE STATE IT WILL
HELP SAVE TIME.
AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND HELP US AVOID POTENTIAL
LITIGATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SO MUCH IS LOW YOU APPROVED IT.
WE DO NOT NEED POWER POINT TO
HIS JOB A SEVERITY GO
[inaudible]
S. WORK.
BUT WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL TO HAVE
MISUSE HERE SHE'S PRESIDENT CEO
OF ADOBE COMMUNITIES TALKING
ABOUT THE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
BUILD MORE DENSELY MISUSED
FORESHORES HAVE FIVE MINUTES --
GIVE YOU A THIRTY SECOND HEADS
UP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE I
REALLY APPRECIATED IN ADDITION
TO BEING THE PRESIDENCY OF ABOUT
COMMUNITIES I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM ON ON THE BOARD AND
HOUSING POLICY TEARS THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
SO ARE YOU NOT MY FIRST FEW
SLIDES ARE REALLY ABOUT THINGS
THAT YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD TODAY
WITH THE MOVE MY LOOK AT A LOCAL
CLOSER OKAY THANK YOU.
WHICH WHICH YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD
ABOUT TODAY WHICH IS --
ARE THE HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS VERY LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
UNTIL THIS FIGHT JUST SORT OF
DEMONSTRATE NUMBERS THAT YOU SEE
YOU'VE ALREADY SEEN TODAY --
A MOMENT OKAY --
OTHER BIRD COMMUNITIES WE WORK
TO ADDRESS THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS AND AS YOU'VE
HEARD FROM OTHERS SPEAKERS TODAY
IT'S REALLY ABOUT WHO'S IMPACTED
BY THIS CRISIS BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT WHEN FAMILIES AND SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH SPECIAL NEEDS
MOVING TOWARD BUILDING.
IT HAS A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
THEIR LIVES WE SEE FAMILY.
FAMILIES EXPERIENCING GREATER
STABILITY AND IN THEIR LIVES YOU
SEE KIDS DOING BETTER IN SCHOOLS
WE SEE --
SENIORS WHO ARE ABLE TO LIVE
LONGER INDEPENDENTLY IN THEIR
HOMES.
AND WE SEE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS OR HAVE
SPECIAL NEEDS HAVE THE SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED TO STAY STABLE IN
THEIR HOME
.
BUT WE WHAT WE ALSO SEE ON THE
OTHER END OF THAT
AROUND THE
ISSUES AND YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OF
THAT TODAY BOTH IN TERMS OF THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE IMPACTED.
BUT BUT OUR LAND USE --
AVAILABILITY IS TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE AND THAT THEIR NEW THERE
NEEDS TO BE INNOVATIVE ZONING
SOLUTION AND REGULATIONS THAT
EXPEDITE THE PRODUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND THEN STUDIES TO SORT OF HOW
HOW THIS IS THE FIRST ONE IS A
PROJECT THAT WE ARE FINISHING
CONSTRUCTION ON AND SOUTH LOS
ANGELES RULING CURRY'S GARDENS.
WHAT WAS REALLY --
SIGNIFICANT ABOUT THIS FROM A
LAND USE PERSPECTIVE SO THIS IS
THE GENTRIFYING NEIGHBORHOOD
RIGHT ACROSS FROM YOU SEE WHERE
WE'VE SEEN A GREAT LOSS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THIS
PARTICULAR PROPERTY WAS ON THE
MARKET.
AND COULD HAVE BEEN SOLD FOR
MARKET RATE HOUSING SO ARE OUR
GOALS HERE WAS TO PRESERVE
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY IN THIS
COMMUNITY. TO INCREASE DENSITY
AS YOU CAN TELL FROM THE SLIDE
IT'S RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET
FROM THE ACTUAL SITE.
INTO COMBAT GENTRIFICATION THAT
WAS HAPPENING IN THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD THROUGH LOCAL
ZONING AND LAND USE WE WERE ABLE
TO TAKE HIS FORTY EIGHT YOU NAY
GARDEN STYLE APARTMENT.
AND AND DEVELOP A HUNDRED AND
FORTY AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS
AT REDUCE PARKING INCORPORATED
COMMUNITY FACILITY IT'S A GREAT
PROJECT BUT IT HAD SOME
CHALLENGES AND I THINK IT'S
CHALLENGES THAT LAND USE COULD
DEFINITELY ADDRESS.
WE HAD A LINK THE LINK THE
ENTITLEMENT PROCESS EVEN AFTER
SIGNIFICANT COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND THERE WAS AN APPEALS PROCESS
THAT THE AND EXTENDED THE THE
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY.
SO THIS PROJECT REQUIRED AS OWN
CHANGE GENERAL PLAN AND THEN
MATT AND WE ALSO UTILIZE THE
DENSITY BONUS.
IF ANY AND IF IT WERE ENDING
CONSTRUCTION DOWN [inaudible]
THE VOTE WE COULD HAVE DELIVERED
pWE THINK ABOUT LAND USE AND THE
PRESENTATION YOU SAW FROM MR
GARCIA EARLIER.
AND HEARD TODAY IT'S JUST THE
THE MISMATCH BETWEEN THE
AVAILABILITY OF MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING ZONE FOR MULTI FAMILY.
AND THEN ARE NEED TO GO THROUGH
THE PROCESS SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU KNOW AS I'VE LOOKED AT
POLICY IS.
CAN WE LOOK AT WAYS T. TO DEAL
WITH ITS OWN CHANGE IN GENERAL
PLAN BY.
NOT JUST LOOKING AT THE ISOLATED
SITE BUT WHAT'S PRECEDENT IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD FOR HOW.
THINGS HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED AGAIN
THIS SITE OLD NEIGHBORHOOD BILL
BACK IN THE NINETEEN TWENTIES
AND THIRTIES PRIMARILY SINGLE
FAMILY DUPLEXES BUT OVER TIME
IT'S BEGAN TO DEVELOP AT THE
CHASE IMPARTS PARCELS WERE JUST
NOT THERE YET.
IS THERE A WAY --
TO TO SOME PRECEDENTS OWNING NOT
JUST BASED UPON THE ADJACENT
PROPERTIES BUT WITH THE
PRESIDENT THAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD THIRTY SECONDS
SURE -- I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THIS
PARTICULAR DEVELOPMENT WAS A
PROJECT THAT WE DO WITH LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THAT
THE PURPOSE OF TIS ONE IS
REALLY TO HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING AVAILABLE
PUBLICLY OWNED THE LAND TO
DEVELOP AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IN THIS CASE WERE ABLE TO DO
THIS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH LA U.
S. T. AND DELIVER NOT ONLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR THE
GENERAL PUBLIC BUT ALSO.
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR THEIR
LOWER WAGE WORKFORCE ALSO HAVING
AVAILABLE PUBLIC PLAN IS REALLY
REALLY CRITICAL AND THEN I JUST
WANT.
TO GET TO MY LAST SLIDE WHICH IS
A PROJECT THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT TO THE LIES IN THE TRANSIT
ORIENTED DID COMMUNITIES DOWN
THE LOS ANGELES.
AND I REALLY JUST FEEL LIKE THAT
IS A REALLY GREAT MOM AND
INCLUDING OF BUT ALSO YOUR
PERCENT AFFORDABLE HAVE THAT
INTEL'S GREAT AND THAT ENOUGH.
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MARKET RATE DEVELOPERS BUT ALSO
THE ADDITIONAL INCENTIVES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
SO IF THERE QUESTIONS LATER ON I
CAN DEFINITELY TALK MORE ABOUT
THE TOC.
SO -- AGAIN
I THINK THIS IS REALLY CRITICAL
AS WE THINK ABOUT HOW TO YOU AND
XCELERATED PRODUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT CREATING
INCENTIVES AND TOOLS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
TO IMPROVE THEIR COMMUNITY PLANS
INCREASE SOUNDING AND BRING MORE
RESOURCES THIS CRAP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS YOU SPREE
GRATEFUL THANKS CHOP TODAY.
WERE --
GRATEFUL THAT MISTER PHILLIPS IS
HERE HE IS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
POLICY LEGISLATION FOR THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION.
AND HE'S GONNA BE DOING A DEEP
DIVE ON GRANNY UNITS AS WE ALSO
CALL EXCESS READ WILLING UNITS
ALSO SOON TO BE CALLED A Y.
CASKEY DWELLING UNIT SO --
THERE WE GO MISTER PHILLIPS THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU HAVE FIVE
MINUTES SO GIVE YOU A THIRTY
SECOND AD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR AND
AND THANK YOU TO THE WHOLE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME AND TEAR
YOUR STAFF FOR ENGAGING WITH US
AHEAD OF TIME I'M HAPPY.
TO BE HERE.
AS YOU POINTED OUT ON BEHALF
CHEN.
WE ARE A PROFESSIONAL --
TREAT ORGANIZATION WE HAVE --
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
THAT REPRESENT PROFESSIONAL
PLANNERS BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE --
SOME GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC --
WITH AN EFFORT OF YOU BUILDING
GREAT COMMUNITIES THROUGH
PLANNING AND THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF COMMENTS TODAY ABOUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF ZONING
OBVIOUSLY THAT.
AS A PROFESSION BEING A PLANNER
TODAY IN CALIFORNIA I FEEL WE
ARE RESPONSIBLE.
TO ADDRESS AND RECTIFY THAT THE
HISTORY THAT --
PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT TODAY
AND ONE OF THE TOOLS FOR DOING
THAT I BELIEVE ARE ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS --
EIGHTY USE GRANNY FLATS DAVID
D'ARCY AND FROM THE THE TURNER
CENTER ADDRESSING THE CHALLENGES
TO DEVELOPING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TODAY AND TWO OF THE HEIGHT
CHALLENGES ON HIS LIST WERE LAND
AFFORDABILITY.
AND NEIGHBORHOOD OPPOSITION AND
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS --
HELP SOLVE BOTH OF THOSE
PROBLEMS THE LAND IS ALREADY
DEVELOPED WE KNOW WHERE IT IS
AND THEY TEND TO BE EITHER
SMALLER UNITS ARE DEVELOPED
WITHIN STRUCTURES THAT ALREADY
EXISTS OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD
OPPOSITION IS IS LESS AND
THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF DISCUSSION
THROUGHOUT EACH OF THE PANELS.
ABOUT EQUITY AND I BELIEVE
EIGHTY USE ASO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS --
EQUITABLE ASPECTS OF LAND USE
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT I'M TO
THE EXTENT THAT EIGHTY USE ARE
DEVELOPED IN AREAS THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY NOT BEEN ACCESSIBLE
AND AFFORDABLE AFFORDABLE PRICES.
THAT INCREASES OPPORTUNITIES --
TO HOUSEHOLDS THAT THAT WOULD
NOT OTHERWISE BE IN THOSE AREAS --
ALSO IT TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE
ARE.
LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS OR
HOMEOWNERS IN AREAS THAT
HISTORICALLY HAVE BEEN UNDER
SERVED --
DEVELOPING AN EIGHTY ON THEIR
PROPERTY CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BUILD EQUITY IN AN INCOME
STREAM SO --
IT CAN HELP ADDRESS AND KEEP
PEOPLE HOUSED.
IN THEIR THEIR LONG TERM
NEIGHBORHOODS --
BUT ALL OF THAT IS RELATED SURE
THAT IT'S THAT LOCAL --
EIGHT ARE REALLY INCREASING
EIGHTY YOU PRODUCTION IN THE
RIGHT PLACES AND INCREASING
AFFORDABILITY --
I DID WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
OF EXAMPLES OF I'M JURISDICTIONS
THAT I THINK ARE DOING --
GOOD GOOD EFFORTS.
TO PROMOTE EIGHTY YOU
DEVELOPMENT --
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE CITY OF SANTA
ROSA.
AND THEY HAVE CHOSEN TO WAIVE
DEVELOPMENT FEES ON EIGHTY YEARS
BUT ONLY FOR SMALLER EIGHTY USE
THAT CREATES AN INCENTIVE TO
BUILD SMALLER UNITS WHICH AS WAS
DISCUSSED BEFORE ARE MORE
AFFORDABLE.
A LARGE EIGHTY YOU THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE THAT IT WOULD BE
AFFORDABLE IT CAN RENT FOR AS
MUCH AS A MARKET RATE UNIT --
BUT CREATING INCENTIVES FOR
SMALL EIGHTY USE MAKES SENSE THE
OTHER ADVANTAGE OF THAT STRATEGY
IS THAT A SMALLER EDU IS LESS
LIKELY TO BURDEN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ANDSERVICES IN A
JURISDICTION --
IF YOU'RE ALLOWING IT BUT BUT
TWELVE HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT AT
YOU THAT HAS THE SAME IMPACT IN
MANY CASES AS A SMALL SINGLE
FAMILY HOUSE AND THAT'S THE
SQUARE FOOTAGE OF THE HOME I
LIVE IN BERKELEY AND THE
EXEMPTING THAT TYPE OF
DEVELOPMENT FROM FEES.
DOESN'T MAKE AS MUCH SENSE SO --
KEEPING AND USING THIS THEFEE
WAIVER AS A WAY TO CREATE AN
INCENTIVE TO DEVELOP SMALLER
MORE AFFORDABLE EIGHTY USE IS A
GREAT TOOL --
ALSO -- FROM
IN THE SAME REGION BUT NAPA
COUNTY --
HAS A LOAN PROGRAM HELP FINANCE
THE CONSTRUCTION OF A TO USE AS
LONG AS THOSE EIGHTY USE OUR
DEED RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE UNITS
AND THAT HELPS CONTROL WHO HAS
ACCESS TO THEM AND WHO BENEFITS
FROM IT --
WHILE OFFSETTING THE COSTS TO
THE HOMEOWNERS --
ALSO BRING UP AN EXAMPLE FROM --
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN THE
JURISDICTION OF AND SOME NEED US
ANOTHER ON THAT THE FORTY SEVEN
LIST BUT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
BEFORE BUT WHEN I AM EFFORT THAT
THEY'VE DONE THAT'S BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL TOWARDS PROMOTING
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
IS THERE --
CITY COMMISSION PRE APPROVED
PLANS FOR EIGHTY USE --
SO THEY HAVE A SUITE OF NINE
DIFFERENT EDIE YOU PLAN SETS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR FREE TO
THE PUBLIC THAT THEY KNOW HAVE
BEEN PRE PERMITTED PRE APPROVED.
THEY CAN COME AND THEY HAVE TO
PAY FOR THEIR OWN --
LITERAL THEIR SITE DESIGN AND
THEIR ARCHITECT TO DO THE
CONSTRUCTION DRAWINGS --
BUT IT SAVES TIME IT SAVES MONEY --
SO IT INCENTIVIZE THE CREATION
AND AT A LOWER COST FOR THE
HOMEOWNER --
SO AS WE'RE THINKING ABOUT WE
INCENTIVES --
I'D ALSO LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT.
SOME.
OTHER PLANNING PRINCIPLES THAT
RUN THROUGH GETTING GETTING
READY FOR EIGHTY YEARS AND
ACTUALLY SOME OF THEM APPLIED AT
THE STREAMLINING AND AND
CONVERSATIONS THAT --
SENATOR MCGUIRE WAS BRINGING UP
EARLIER IN THE THAT PANEL --
BUT ABOUT A CONTEXT SENSITIVITY.
THE ANSWERS THAT WORK IN CERTAIN
JURISDICTIONS ARE NOT THE SAME
THAT THAT WORK IN OTHERS AND
PARTICULARLY --
WITHIN RURAL PORTIONS OF THE
STATE -- AS
AN ORGANIZATION AN EPA WOULD
WOULD SUPPORT --
EIGHTY USE AND ALMOST ANY A ONE
SINGLE EIGHTY YOU IN ALMOST ANY
EXISTING STRUCTURE --
BUT THEN LOOKING AT MORE
INTENSIFICATION THAN THAT AND
RURAL CONTEXT --
RUNS THE RISK OF POTENTIALLY.
ALLOWING TOO MUCH DEVELOPMENT
OUTSIDE OF AREAS THAT ARE WELL
SERVED BY TRANSIT INCREASING V.
M. T. NGH T. EMISSIONS.
AND BEING IN CONFLICT WITH THE
AGRICULTURAL AND PRESERVATION
EFFORTS -- I
ALSO WANTED TO MENTION SIR THANK
YOU THE DIFFERENCE.
BETWEEN.
URBAN AND RURAL WHEN IT COMES TO
SAFETY AND AND FIRE HAZARDS --
ALLOWING INTENSIFIED DEVELOPMENT --
IN.
EVEN IF YOU TAKE AN X. --
THE RULES THAT WORK THERE SHOULD
BE DIFFERENT THAN THE RULES IN
PARADISE --
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT.
THE LAST THING THAT I WILL I
WILL COVER --
BEFORE MY TIME EXPIRES IS.
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE PLANNING
FOR GROWTH AND THAT PUTTING THE
GROWTH IN AREAS THAT CAN ABSORB-IT --
ALLOWING EASY USE AGAIN AND
URBAN AREAS THAT ARE WELL SERVED
BY MUNICIPAL SERVICES MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE --
BUT THOSE SEEM RULES DON'T
NECESSARILY APPLY IN RURAL
CONTEXT WHERE WERE SERVED BY --
SEPTIC SIR WELL AND THEY CAN
ABSORB THE SAME AMOUNT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE AND I THINK THAT
THAT SAME CONCEPT RUNS THROUGH --
SOME OF THE THE STREAMLINING AND
AND OTHER EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
THE PLANNING FOR THE GROWTH IS
PART OF MAKING SURE THAT THE
GROWTH HAPPENS AND I'LL I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ON
ANY OF THOSE TOPICS THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR SUPPOSED VERY GRATEFUL.
WITH A BIT OPEN IT UP FROM THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR START WITH
SENATOR ABOUT.
I LIKE THE MEMBERS.
TO THE PANEL TO MAKE COMMENTS
ABOUT.
IN IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE A GOOD
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY YOU THINK
WE OUGHTA.
START LIVING IN SMALLER HOUSING
WHICH THE YOU KNOW LIKE.
YOU KNOW LIKE LIKE WITH OKAY --
ALSO THIS BECAUSE I'M OLDER THAN
ALL YOU PEOPLE.
WHEN I WAS A KID --
YOU KNOW WE WE OF COURSE OUR
FAMILY WE HAD TWELVE IN OUR
FAMILY BUT I FIGURED OUT IT WAS
ABOUT. NINETY SQUARE FEET PER.
PERSON IN OUR FAMILY I DON'T
KNOW.
SOME OF YOU LIVED IN THAT WITH
TWELVE PEOPLE ON A THREE BEDROOM
TWO BATH HOUSE [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
YOU KNOW [inaudible]
BUT BUT JUST THE WAY THE WAY
THIS SIZE OF THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THE HOUSING UNIT.
AND AND DO YOU THINK THAT'S PART
OF THE PROBLEM.
WITH AFFORDABILITY IS THAT.
THE HOUSING STOCK THAT WE HAVE
THE IS JUST GETTING.
MORE OF THESE LARGE.
MORE EXPENSIVE THERE NEVER THERE
DOES KIND OF UNITS ARE NEVER
GOING.
TO FILTER DOWN.
TO AFFORDABILITY AT ALL YOU KNOW
THE ODD BUT I LIKE TO HEAR THE
COMMENTS ABOUT THE SIZE --
OF THE HOUSING UNITS THAT WE
APPROVING CALIFORNIA.
WHERE THEY WERE GOING WELL I CAN
ADDRESSES RELIEF AN
ENVIRONMENTAL PERSPECTIVE A
SMALLER UNIT IS DEFINITELY
CARRYING ON A MUCH SMALLER?
CARBON FOOTPRINT --
YOU HAVE MUCH LESS --
ENERGY USAGE WATER USAGE AND IF
YOU'RE CLOSER TO JOBS SERVICES
RETAIL YOU CAN WALK BIKE TAKE
TRANSIT OR IF YOU DO HAVE TO
DRIVE OR NOT TO BE DRIVING AS
FAR AS IF YOU'RE IN AN OUTLYING
AREAIN A BIGGER HOME.
SO THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT AND THAT WAS ONE OF THE FOR
A HOUSING SCENARIO WHERE IF YOU
HAD A MORE COMPACT INFILL TYPE
OF HOUSING SCENARIO YOU COULD
SAY PEOPLE A LOT OF MONEY.
IN THE QUESTIONS WE DON'T WANNA
BE REQUIRING PEOPLE EVEN THOUGH
THAT'S A SENSITIVE SUBJECT RIGHT
PEOPLE SO WILL CLIMATE POLICIES
GONNA REQUIRES ALL THE LIVE IN
SOME RABBIT HUTCH IN A IN A
DENSE HONG KONG LIKE CITY AND
THAT'S NOT REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE TO MEET OUR
CLIMATE.
GOALS IT'S REALLY NOT PROVIDING
THE OPTION OF A SMALLER UNIT
THAT REDUCES PEOPLE NOT ONLY
THEIR ENERGY COSTS BUT THERE
TRANSPORTATION COSTS TO AND
WE'RE NOT BUILDING ENOUGH OF
THOSE SMALLER UNITS I THINK IT'S
ABSOLUTE CORRECT THAT BECAUSE
OUR INFILL AREAS ARE MAJOR JOB
CENTERS HAVE.
RESTRICTED HOUSINGGROWTH IT'S
PUSHED OUT HOUSING OUT TO EDGE
COMMUNITIES WHERE BUILDERS ARE
BUILDING BIGGER PRODUCT BUT WHEN
YOU FACTOR IN THOSE ENERGY COSTS
AS TRANSPORTATION COSTS IT'S
PUTTING A HUGE SQUEEZE ON
CALIFORNIANS AND WE'RE REALLY
STARTING TO HEMORRHAGE.
MIDDLE CLASS RESIDENTS AS A
RESULT.
I JUST LIKE TO ADD TO THAT THANK
YOU SENATOR FOR YOUR QUESTION I
AS NEAR QUESTION IN THE LAST
PANEL AS WELL AND ONE OF THE
WAYS THAT SAN DIEGO IS GOING TO
TACKLE THIS IS TO TRY.
TO INCENTIVIZE THE DEVELOPMENT
OF SMALLER UNITS BY AM CHANGING
AND THE SCALE OF OUR DEVELOPMENT
IMPACT FEES RIGHT NOW IT'S THE
SAME DEVELOPMENT IMPACT THE
WHETHER YOU BUILD A TEN THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT UNIT OR SIX HUNDRED
SQUARE FOOT UNIT.
SO THAT'S A THAT'S A STUDY THAT
THAT WERE WORKING ON AND WE HOPE
TO TO CHANGE THOSE FEES TO
INCENT THOSE SMALLER UNITS.
THANK YOU.
THE THE SIMPLE ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION IS YES --
BUT BUT I WANT TO THINK ABOUT IT
FROM AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PERSPECTIVE AND WE'RE WE'RE
BUILDING AND I FEEL LIKE.
THE THE PRODUCTS THAT WERE BILL.
OUR ART IN GENERAL ARM FOR OUR
APPROPRIATE AND ME WE ARE
PROBABLY SOMEWHERE AROUND YOU
KNOW TWELVE THIRTEEN HUNDRED FOR
A THREE BEDROOM UNITS SO THAT'S
PROBABLY WHAT YOUR FAMILY WITH
US ONE HOUSE.
RIGHT --
YOURS WAS THE 1-000-010-0050
SQUARE FEET SELECT A BRIGHT SO I
I FEEL LIKE --
SO HE'S DOING RIGHT WITHIN THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INDUSTRY
WE'VE DEFINITELY GOTTEN TO A
PLACE OF BUILDING COMPACT
EFFICIENT UNITSTO MATCH THE
HOUSEHOLD CIDER POPULATION THAT
WERE SERVING.
AND SERVED THERE'S A A FEW
THEMES THAT ARE BETTER AND PLAY
WITH AN EIGHT I TOUCHED ON ONE
OF THEM BRIEFLY WITH THE IN THE
EIGHTY YOU CONTEXT AS A SMALLER
EIGHTY YOU IS IS LESS LIKELY TO
MORE LIKELY TO BE AFFORDABLE AND
LESS LIKELY TO BURDEN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IN.
THE SAME WAY A LARGER ONE WAY SO
THAT HAS A A DOUBLE BENEFIT
THERE -- BUT
IT AT THE SAME TIME --
TO PICK UP ON A LITTLE BIT OF
WHAT MS HUGHES WAS JUST TALKING
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
STILL PLANNING --
FOR FAMILIES AND AND AND HOW ONE
THIRD ONLY BE ONE HOUSING
TYPOLOGY OBVIOUSLY --
BEING ABLE TO BUILD MORE
EFFICIENTLY --
IS.
IS AN IMPORTANT AN IMPORTANT
STRATEGY TO OF CONTROLLING COSTS
AND INCREASING DENSITY TO
PROVIDE MORE OPTIONS --
BUT AT THE SAME THERE IF THERE
IS.
IT WILL NEVER TOTALLY GO AWAY TO
HAVE HAVE THE DEMAND FOR LARGER
UNITS ARE LUXURY UNITS THERE CAN
BE ROOM FOR THAT IN THE MARKET.
AS LONG AS THAT'S NOT COMING AT
THE EXPENSE OF MEETING THE OTHER
NEEDS THAT ARE ARE OUT THERE I
THINK I THINK WHAT I'M SEEING IN
SAN JOSE AND SILICON VALLEY IS.
THERE'S A LOT OF FAMILIES THAT
[inaudible]
FELICE E. [inaudible]
THE VALLEY.
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO LIVE IN AN
AREA WHERE THERE IS.
THEY CAN BUY THEY CAN IT WENT TO
THEM AFFORDABILITY IS TO BUY --
A THREE THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
HOUSE.
YOU'RE ON THE MOVE OUT AND TRACY
ERRORS --
MODESTO OR SOMEPLACE
[inaudible]
PATTERSON OF THERE ARE MY
COMMUTING AS LONG AS THEY GO
BACK TO THAT THREE THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT HOUSE.
AND I THINK THERE'S SOME KIND OF
WITH THE SOME WRONG WITH THAT
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF LIKE WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
TRANSPORTATION ALL THE THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS AND WE HAVE TO
TURN AROUND TO REWARD PEOPLE
THAT -- ONE
LIVE IN A DIFFERENT KIND OF
ENVIRONMENT AND AND FROM A
PLANNING STANDPOINT SO.
RESTAURANT THANK YOU NO THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER ABOUT VERY
GRATEFUL.
TURN OVER CENTER Y. CALFSKIN IN
SENATOBIA.
SO THIS IS A SECTION ON
STRATEGIC COURSE SPECIFIC
STRATEGIES AND THERE IS SOME
TENSION BETWEEN LOOK LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE.
JUST MENTION THAT --
AND I GUESS IN THE EIGHTY YOU
CONTENT WE HAD WE PASSED THE
BILL IN TWO THOUSAND TWO THAT
SAID EVERYBODY NEEDED TO EVERY
CITY HAD THE PASSAGE.
A SECOND UNIT PORTENTS AND
EVERYBODY PASSED TO SET ALL FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO CITIES PASSED
SECOND UNIT ORDINANCE AND YOU
LOOK AT THAT FIFTEEN YEARS OR
TWELVE YEARS BETWEEN. TWO
THOUSAND THREE AND TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN BEFORE.
SB TEN SIXTY NINE GOT IT AND
THERE WAS LIKE ONE UNIT TO UNIT
ZERO UNITS ZERO UNITS SO THEY
ALL HAVE THESE BILL FELT GOOD
ABOUT THEIR LOSS TO DATE BUT
NOTHING GOT BUILT.
SEDAN NOW GOING --
TO TO SIXTEEN LOCAL ORDINANCES
FOUR EIGHT IF HE DIDN'T COMPLY
WITH TEN SIXTY NINE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE YOU KNOW THE REQUIRED --
PARKING IN THE BOOK PARKING WAS
REQUIRED WITHIN TRANSIT NONE THE
ROLLER IS BETWEEN TRANSIT.
ONLY TWO HUNDRED OF THE FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO CITIES HAVE
PASS NEW EIGHTY YOU ORDINANCES.
FOR THE CAT NOT EVEN HALF SOME
FOR COMPLYING WITH STATE LAWS
BUT OTHERS USE WE SIT HERE ON
YEAR.
THREE AND SOME OF US ARE
CHATTERING ABOUT THE IMPACT FEES
TEN AND HOMEOWNERSHIP WHICH I
BELIEVE IS NOT A GOOD INCENTIVE
BECAUSE IT'S IT'S IT RESTRICTS.
HOW CAN YOU HELP US OUT WITH
THIS STRATEGY WE IT SEEMS AS
THOUGH WE'RE SAYING THIS IS WHT
WE WANT YOU TO GO?
BACK IN 200-022-00016 AND THEIR
SISTER FINANCE.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WHEN WE'VE
SAID YOUR YOUR LONG ANSWER FOR
YOU AND THEY'RE STILL PASSING
THEY'RE STILL IN FORCING TEN
THOUSAND MINIMUM LOT SIZE FOR AN
EIGHTY YOU FOR INSTANCE.
STRATEGY SOME ASSISTANCE I KNOW
SAN DIEGO HAS ACTUALLY DONE A
LOT OF OLD JOB.
IT WILL.
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN LAWS I THINK
WERE OBSERVER VERY EFFECTIVE I
MEAN YOU'RE RIGHT THAT THERE'S
NOT 1100% COMPLIANCE BUT THE
THERE'S BEEN A BLOOM AND EIGHTY
YOU CONSTRUCTION --
THROUGHOUT JURISDICTIONS AND
IT'S IT'S JUST RETURN THAT TO
PART OF THE CONVERSATION A LOT
OF JURISDICTIONS.
BUT MAYBE HAD ONE ON THE BOOKS
BUT WERE IN NOW.
REINVESTED IN TRYING TO PROMOTE
THAT SO A THE ATTENTION THAT'S
BEEN RETURNED TO HIS BàN --
REALLY HELPFUL EIGHT I THINK
THAT -- IN
SOME WAYS.
GIVING THEN THE THE LAWS THAT
ARE NOW ON THE BOOKS TIME TO
WORK AND CONTINUE TO WORK.
IN THAT CONTEXT IS GOOD BUT
BROADENING YOU.
DO YOUR QUESTION ABOUT HOW DO
YOU.
MAKE SURE THAT JURISDICTION'S
ARE COMPLAINING I FEEL.
THAT --
ACTUALLY THE THE EIGHTY YOU THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN EIGHTY YOU
LEGISLATION IS A GOOD MODEL
BECAUSE IT SET VERY SPECIFIC
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS ABOUT
WHERE THINGS NEEDED TO BE --
PERMITTED IT ALLOWED THE
JURISDICTION SOME DISCRETION TO
GO THROUGH A PLANNING PROCESS
AND COME UP WITH.
THEIR LOCAL STANDARDS BUT THEN
ONCE THOSE WERE SAT IT'S A
MINISTERIAL TIME LIMITED
APPROVAL PROCESS THERE'S NO MORE
SEEK WEATHER'S NO MORE --
OPPORTUNITY FOR NAME BE
INVOLVEMENT SO HAVING.
THE THAT SORT OF DYNAMIC BETWEEN
THE STATE'S SETTING PARAMETERS
GIVING.
WITH SPECIFIC IN TIME
REQUIREMENTS AND CONSEQUENCES --
BUT GIVING CITIES THE
OPPORTUNITY THEN. TO TO COMPLY
AND IF THEY DON'T THEN THE
STATE'S STANDARDS SET THE
BASELINE AND AND THEY'VE MISSED
OUT ON THEIR OPPORTUNITY.
THAT'S THEIR CHOICE THAT MODEL
SEEMS TO TO WORK PRETTY WELL IN
TERMS OF CREATING --
AN INCENTIVE FOR CITIES TO
COMPLY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO SOME PLANNING WORK AND THEN
HAVING --
CONSEQUENCES IF THEY DON'T.
SEE YOUR QUESTION GOES BEYOND
THE EIGHTY YEARS I'M I WOULD SAY
AND WORKING WITH ANY STATE
LEGISLATION THAT'S COME DOWN
LOCALLY FROM WAY BACK WITH SB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN TO OTHER.
SORT OF MULTI FAMILY PROJECTS
THAT DEALT WITH IT YOU KNOW THE
EIGHTY SIX CITIES AT THE LA
COUNTY THEY ALL IMPLEMENTED VERY
DIFFERENTLY.
AND SOME CHOOSE --
TO DOT TEMPERAMENT THESE --
POLICIES SO I THINK THERE IS
THERE IS I THINK MORE THAT COULD
BE PUT IN PLACE IN TERMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND WHAT COULD HAPPEN AND WHAT
ARE THE CONSEQUENCES ONE
POLICIES ARE NOT IMPLEMENTED AND
MAYBE THERE'S A HOUSING.
SPECIALIST WITHIN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE THAT THAT'S YOU
KNOW THEIR JOB IS TO LOOK AT HOW
LOCALITIES ARE IMPLEMENTING --
LAND USE POLICY BUT THE THE
OTHER THING IS CAN WE TIE
INCENTIVES OTHER FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES AT THE STATE LEVEL TO
AYE THEIR REWARD THROUGH CITIES
THAT ARE DOING RIGHT WELL AROUND
THOSE HOT THERE HOUSING POLICY
OR I DON'T WANT TO SAY --
PUNISH BUT YOU KNOW TÁI
INCENTIVES.
TO IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE HOUSING
POLICIES AS WELL.
AND I THINK I JUST LIKE THE TO
QUICKLY ADD IN TERMS OF THE
STRATEGY AND WE WE ARE
PERMITTING A LOT MORE EIGHTY USE
NOW.
PREVIOUSLY WE PERMITTED A LOT OF
GUEST QUARTERS RIGHT SO THAT'S
THE SAME UNIT BUT WITHOUT THAT
KITCHEN FACILITY AND SO.
PERHAPS WE SHOULD HAVE SOME SORT
OF A LOCAL AND THE GUEST
QUARTERS THAT ACTUALLY DATA NOW
HAVE.
KITCHENS --
IN TERMS OF FINANCIAL
FEASIBILITY --
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO SET ASIDE --
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
OUR GENERAL FUND DOLLARS TO
WAIVE THE WATER AND SEWER FEES
CITY COUNCIL APPROVED WEIGHING
THAT ARE WAVING THAT THE DIFFIE
IS --
SANDBAG JUST WAVE TO OUR
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION FEE SO
WE'VE NOW WAVED.
UPWARDS OF TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN FEES AND IF SOMEONE
CAN CAPITALIZE ON IN CITY THIS
IS FREE DESIGN TEMPLATES MAYBE
THEY CAN SAVE ANOTHER TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THERE SO WE'VE
JUST SHAVED FORTY GRAND.
OFF OF THE PROXIMATE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO BUILD AN
EIGHTY SO THAT'S THAT'S
SIGNIFICANT AND I I DEFINITELY
THINK THAT THOSE NUMBERS WILL
CONTINUE.
I THINK A LOT OF GREAT POINTS
HERE RAISED I WOULD JUST SAY YOU
DESCRIBE AS ATTENTION CENTER
RIGHT HOUSE GIVE ME A LOT OF IS
KIND OF A CAT AND MOUSE GAME.
FOR EXAMPLE LET'S SAY SENATE
BILL FIFTY WERE TO PASS AND
MANDATORY UP ZONING BOARD HAPPEN
AROUND LOCAL DROUGHT TRANSIT
STOPS YOU STILL SEE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BEEN A BURNING UP
THE PERMITTING PROCESS TO TRY.
TO YOU KNOW AND I CUT OUT YOU
KNOW HOW GAME THAT --
THAT UP ZONING SO YOU KNOW TO
CERTAIN EXTENT I THINK THAT
DYNAMIC IS EVERY HEARD IT WITH
THE RENO DISCUSSION THAT YOU HAD
EARLIER WHERE YOU HAVE THIS
BEING A PROCESS THAT THE LOCALS
IN THE REGION'S REALLY KND OF
CAME TO ALSO. TO TO AVOID HAVING
A REALLY COMPLY SO I THINK HOW
LOCALS ARE DOING IN TERMS OF
COMPLIANCE AND MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S A PROCESS TO ENFORCE --
AND ALSO FOLLOW UP LEGISLATION
IS OFTEN NEEDED I DO THINK THE
POINT THAT MISUSE MADE AROUND --
LINKING FUNDING IS REALLY
CRITICAL TO TRY TO GET LOCALS --
TO TO REALLY STEP UP BUT IN I
WOULD SAY YOU COULD LINK GAS TAX
FUNDS OF THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
TO HOUSING PRODUCTION AS ONE
METHOD AND SIMPLY HAVING MORE --
YOU GRANTS AVAILABLE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
YOU KNOW I WANT ONE COMMENT I
HEARD ABOUT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AT
HEIR OFTEN DESCRIBED AS A CHEAP
DATE IF YOU DANGLE SOME GRANT
MONEY FROM WILL COME ABOUT YOU
KNOW HOW COMPETE EACH OTHER TO
TRY TO GET THOSE FUNDS SO.
THAT CERTAINLY IS ANOTHER OPTION
TO TRY TO GET THAT GET SOME
TRACTION BUT YOU KNOW IF THE A
LOT OF THE MANDATES REQUIRE A
LOT OF STAFF TIME FOR LOCALS
THAN THERE ARE BITS CAN BE MUCH
HARDER FOR THEM TO COMPLY SO I
THINK SIMPLY REMOVING BARRIERS.
REMOVING DISCRETION SO THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO GO TO SEE WHAT
PROCESS SEES ON NEW LOCAL
PROCEDURES ARE DEDICATE A LOT OF
STAFF TIME TO IT NOW THEY HAVE
THE POLITICAL COVER TO TELL
THEIR CONSTITUENTS I'M SORRY THE
STATE'S DOING THIS TO US.
I THINK THOSE TEND TO BE THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL PASS FORWARD.
AN I AM --
TH PROPOSING AN AMNESTY PROGRAM
STATEWIDE SO THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND UNITS.
COULD BECOME GET TEN YEARS TO
GET LEGITIMATE BUT A THEY WOULD
ALSO GET IMMEDIATE RE THEIR
NECKS ON THE NEXT BATCH SO THAT
THE THERE'S SOME CARE IT THERE --
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT MORE HOURS
LATER I GET.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ON DUTY
QUICKTIME CHECK WITH THE
COMMITTEE WERE A FEW MINUTES
BEFORE FOR AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WITH THE PLENTY TIME ALSO
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT WE MISS
CABALLERO WHO WILL BE SPEAKING
HERE.
IT'S MORE LIKE A YOU COULD.
WRITE THE TURNOVER CYNICAL
BUREAU THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
I REALLY ENJOYED THIS --
THIS PANEL ME JUST JUST SAY THAT --
I'M A BIG PROPONENT OF
INCENTIVES I NEVER CONSIDERED
MYSELF WHEN I WAS IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT A CHEAP DATE.
WHATEVER IT TAKES --
BUT LET ME LET ME TELL YOU WHAT
I THINK IS IS THE TENSION THAT I
FEEL IN TERMS OF THE DISTRICT
THAT I REPRESENT --
I'VE I'VE REPRESENTED SALINAS
BOTH LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL AND
NOW IT THAT BACK IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND NOW WITH AT THE SENATE BUT I
ALSO INCLUDE A LARGE PORTION OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND IT'S THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PORTION IT'S
ACCEPTING.
A LOT OF THE REFUGEES FROM THE
BAY AREA THAT ARE LOOKING FOR
THESE BIGGER BIGGER HOMES AND I
THINK THE CHALLENGE THAT IN MY
MIND AS WE LOOK.
MOVING FORWARD TO THE KINDS OF
POLICIES THAT CAN FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE HOW PEOPLE SEE HOUSING --
IS IS THIS IS A BET THE LACK OF
A OF A RECOGNITION THAT
AGRICULTURAL RANGELAND AND OPEN
SPACE PARK LAND HAS.
THE ABILITY TO SEQUESTERED.
GREENHOUSE GASES AND THAT IT
SHOULD KING ABOUT SO BEFORE WE
GET TO A VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
KIND OF TAX ON HOW FAR ARE YOU
COMMUTING WHICH HAS THE PERVERSE
IMPACT ON THE POOR PEOPLE
BECAUSE THOSE WEALTHY ENOUGH
THEY CAN STAY IN THAT COMMUNITY.
STAY IN THE LIVES THEY ACTUALLY
WORK CLOSE TO THEIR JOBS THOSE
THAT CAN AFFORD MOVE FURTHER AND
FURTHER OUT AND IN SO THAT THE
CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE IS TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO INCENTIVIZE
THE DEVELOPMENT I REALLY ENJOYED
HEARING WHAT SAN DIEGO IS DOING.
BECAUSE BECAUSE EUROPE YOU'RE A
BIG COMMUNITY AND AND EAT AND
YOU'RE PUSHING PEOPLE INTO SOME
OF THE OTHER.
POOR COMMUNITIES PROJECT THE
ABILITY TO CHANGE IT FOR A BURKE
A BROAD GROUP OF PEOPLE AND SO
THE SO THE CHALLENGE IS TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO INCENTIVIZE
SOME OF THE SMALLER UNITS.
PEOPLE WANT TO LIVE IN THESE YOU
KNOW TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED SQUARE
FOOT BUT SOME PEOPLE ARE JUST
LOOKING FOR SPACE THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO SHARE WITH ANYBODY
SO THE ABILITY TO MOVE INTO AN
EIGHT HUNDRED OR A THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT --
UNIT IS REALLY IMPORTANT SO I
PART OF I GUESS PART OF THE
CHALLENGE THAT I SEE IS THAT --
FOR US TO INCENTIVIZE PURCHASING.
A ELECTRIC VEHICLE. FOR SOMEONE
WHO WOULD ALREADY BY IT IN IN A
BUT OF THEIR OWN ACCORD INSTEAD
OF INVESTING IN.
TRANSIT TO THE SUBURBS AND TO
RURAL CALIFORNIA MEANS THAT
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO BE
CONNECTED IN A WAY THAT MAKES IT
CONVENIENT FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE
TO BE GIVEN A VOUCHER. TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION TO THEIR JOB
SIXTY MILES AWAY SO WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE REORGANIZED --
THAT THE WAY THAT WE'RE DOING
BUSINESS IN A AND AND AS A
SNAPSHOT FOR THE FIRST TIME THAT
I'VE BEEN IN PUBLIC OFFICE I HAD
TO COMMUNITIES.
IN MY DISTRICT AT TOWN HALL
MEETINGS PEOPLE WERE TALKING
ABOUT -- A
INITIATIVE TO STOP GROWTH AND
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE TRAFFIC IT'S
NOT BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
GROW IT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY THAT
THERE'S THIS NECESSITY OR THEY
WANT DON'T WANT OUT HOUSES.
IT'S BECAUSE THE TRAFFIC HAS
BECOME SO BAD AND WE WILL NEVER
GET RESOURCES FOR THOSE THAT
TRAFFIC CONGESTION BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE IT'S
RURAL.
AND SO I MEAN I THINK THAT'S
PART OF THE TENSION IN TERMS OF
THE INCENTIVES ASFAR AS I'M
CONCERNED IS THE ONLY WAY WE'RE
GOING TO GET LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
SAY YES WE WERE.
IT AND ALL OF THOSE COUNCIL
MEMBERS BY THE WAY ARE KIND OF
APPALLED AT THIS GRASSROOTS
MOVEMENT BUT UNTIL WE CAN SHOW
THEM THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING
TO TAKE CARE OF SOME OF THE
TRAFFIC ISSUES ARE NOT GOING TO
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BUILD SO --
I DON'T THERE'S NOT A QUESTION
THERE BUT I JUST THINK THAT AS
WE START TALKING ABOUT.
HOW DO WE REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GASES IT CAN'T JUST BE --
THAT THAT WERE BUYING ELECTRIC
VEHICLES IT WE ALSO HAVE TO
INCLUDE HOW DO WE INCLUDE THE
SUBURBS AND AND THE AND THE
RURAL COMMUNITIES AS WELL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH HIGHER.
UP PLEASE REAL QUICK OH YEAH
WELL I WOULD JUST SAY YOU'RE
WITH AS I MENTIONED MY
PRESENTATION LECTURE VEHICLES
ALONE ARE GOING TO GET US THERE
WE DEFINITELY NEED TO LOOK INTO
THOSE.
CARBON SEQUESTRATION BENEFITS
AND JUST RAISE A LOT OF GREAT
POINTS BUT JUST ON THAT THE MTV
QUESTION IF THOSE DOLLARS ON A
EVAN THERE'S A V. M. T. V. WHICH
EVENTUALLY WE NEED TO MOVE TO
WHERE TO FIND TRANSIT.
BIBLE TRANSIT OPTIONS FOR THOSE
PEOPLE LIVING IN OUR COMMUNITIES
OUR EDGE COMMUNITIES I THINK
THAT WOULD PROVIDE A REAL
ECONOMIC AND QUALITY OF LIFE
BENEFIT FOR THEM. TO GET TO WORK
WITHOUT HAVING TO COMMUTE IN A
SINGLE THANK YOU WITH YOU BUT WE
BETTER BILL THE SYSTEM BEFORE WE
START DOING VMT I'M JUST SAYING
IF PEOPLE WERE MAD ABOUT A GAS
TAX BEFORE.
YOU START ADDING BE EMPTY ON TOP
OF THAT IN MY DISTRICT THEY'RE
THEY'RE TRAVELING AT LEAST SIXTY
MILES INTO AND THAT TAKES A
COUPLE OF HOURS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH HAPPIER.
THE GENTLEMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO SAY
THANK YOU TO OUR PANEL GREAT
DISCUSSION TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING
TIME AND IF YOU TRAVEL FAR AND
WIDE TO BE ABLE TO BE HERE WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
RETURN IT BACK OVER TO THE
CHAIRMAN I TO BE ABLE TO RUN OUR
PUBLIC PORTION PART OF THE
HEARING FUTURE.
AND AGAIN THANK YOU TO ALL THE
PANELISTS WILL NOW --
OPENING UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS
IF FOLKS WOULD LINE UP ON THE
LEFT IS A MICROPHONE --
STANDING THERE --
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE TWO
MINUTES AND IF YOU COULD --
WOULD IF YOU'RE WILLING TO STATE
YOUR NAME AND IF YOU DO HAVE AN
AFFILIATION THANK YOU.
THE SECOND --
IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATORS
FOR SO I WANT TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR PUTTING THE SAP PROGRAM
THESE PANELS TOGETHER THEY WERE.
REALLY INFORMATIVE --
I CURRENTLY SERVE ON THE NEVADA
CITY COUNCIL AND HAVE EVER SINCE
JUNE OF NINETEEN NINETY FIVE AND
I ALSO AND PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
BUT A LOT OF TIME AND THEN AND
SO IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU AGAIN
FOR A MUCH SO.
I'M YOU KNOW OVER IT WHEN WHEN I
WAS FIRST ELECTED WITHIN THE
FIRST WEEK I LEARNED ONE THING
FROM OUR CITY MANAGER ONE IS
THAT HOUSING DOESN'T PAY FOR
ITSELF.
THE STATE NEEDS TO MAKE SURE
THAT HOUSING PAYS FOR THE
SERVICES.
THAT CITIES PROVIDE.
NEVADO IS A POOR PROPERTY TAX
CITY WE GET FIVE CENTS ON EACH
DOLLAR A PROPERTY TAX THAT'S
PAID WHERE ES SAFE.
CITY -- NOT
FAR FROM WHERE WE LIVE IN
SENATE'S HOW MORROW THEY GET
TWENTY THREE CENTS. FOR THE
DOLLAR BILL VALLEY GETS TWENTY
SIX CENTS ON THE DOLLAR WE CAN'T
PROVIDE ALL THE SERVICES BASED
ON THE FIVE CENTS PER DOLLAR.
THE STATE NEEDS TO DO SOMETHING
A SEVERITY FOR THOSE CITIES THAT
WERE FORMED AFTER --
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT HAD A LOW
MIL RATE WHEN ALL THE PROPERTY
TAXES WERE FROZEN WHEN PROP
THIRTEEN WAS PASSED.
STATE NEEDS TO HELP YOU SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE THE SERVICES ONE THING
WE HAVE AN ADVANTAGE WE HAD
HAMILTON BASE CLOSURE.
SO WE WERE ABLE TO WITH
REDEVELOPMENT WE USED A 100%.
LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN WE USE A
100% OF THE MONEY FROM
REDEVELOPMENT. TO BUILD HOUSING
ON HAMILTON AND SIX HUNDRED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS WE WERE
ALSO ABLE TO SET ASIDE A FUND.
SO THAT EACH YEAR MONEY GOES
INTO HER GENERAL FUND TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES FOR THOSE OVER
THREE THOUSAND HOMES.
AND WE JUST APPROVED THIS LAST
TWO YEARS FOR MORE DEVELOPMENTS
IN HAMILTON FOR HOUSING.
I'M THE OTHER THING THAT WE
COULD DEFINITELY USE IS VACANT
HOMES WE HAVE A LOT OF VACANT
HOMES AND IN OUR COMMUNITY WHY
DOESN'T THE STATE SAVE A VACANT
HOME AS STAYS VACANT FOR MORE
THAN THREE TO FIVE YEARS.
WHY DON'T YOU PER HABIT OR SAY
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
KEEP YOUR PROP?
THIRTEEN OUT PROPERTY TAX LIMIT
THAT IS A STATE LAW THAT COULD
VERY WELL HELP ENCOURAGE A LOT
OF PEOPLE WHO KEEP THOSE HOME
VACANT FOR TEN YEARS OR LONGER.
TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO BRING IT
BACK INTO PRODUCTION --%
ALSO TO I REALLY FIRMLY BELIEVE
AND I AT THAT LARGE BUSINESSES.
NEED TO PROVIDE AND BUILD
HOUSING FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES
WHERE THEIR JOBS ARE.
WE NEED THE CITIES YOU KNOW WE
DON'T BUILD THE HOUSING --
WE AND THE SMALL FINDS THAT WE
DO YOU GET WE HELP THE NONPROFIT
DEVELOPERS LIKE EDH AND HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY AND HOMEWARD BOUND
I MEAN.
SIR MAGUIRE'S BEEN TO HAMILTON
IS SEEN WHAT NEVADA HAS DONE
WHAT WE'VE BEEN WE'VE BUILT MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT ALL THE
OTHER TEN CITIES IN THE COUNTY.
SO PLEASE I AGREED WITH THE
SENATOR HAVE A RARE --
THAT WE NEED INCENTIVES AND NOT
FIT ALL PLEASE GIVE US SOME
TOOLS.
AND WE WILL DEFINITELY PRODUCE
THE HOUSING THAT WE NEED.
THANK YOU A SECOND.
HELLO SAYS A MATINEE HERE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA U. M. B.
I'M HERE JUST TO READ IT
REITERATE THEIR POSITION --
THAT THEY BELIEVE THE STATE
REALLY SHOULD COME IN.
AND REDUCE SOME OF THE LOCAL
ZONING RESTRICTIONS --
TO ALLOW.
MORE HOUSING TO BE BUILT --
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND I'M
REALLY DO ENCOURAGE --
INCENTIVE BASED --
INCENTIVE BASED LIKE.
A AND SENATE BASED POLICIES HE'S
ME LIKE RINA --
AND AN INCREASE HOUSING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THANK YOU.
HI SUSAN CURSE FROM LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING AND TO ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE ON THE PANEL
IT'S REALLY BEEN HELPFUL AND
INFORMATIVE.
SO A COUPLE OF RESPONSES TO THE
THINGS THAT HAVE COME UP ONE IS
THERE'S BEEN THE REFERENCE TO
THE CAT AND MOUSE GAME OR THE
TENSIONS THAT EXIST BETWEEN
CITIES AND LEGISLATORS.
I WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT YOU
HAD ONE PERSON WHO WAS A VERY
STRONG PANELISTS THIS IS
CAROLINE COLEMAN FROM THE GIVE
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
OTHERWISE IT SEEMS LIKE THERE
WAS A REAL ABSENCE OF THOSE
PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE REPRESENTING
CITY COUNCILS THE WAY PAT
ACKLAND JUST SPOKE ON BEHALF OF
WHAT.
HAS BEEN HAPPENING IN HER
COMMUNITY AND KNOWING THE NUMBER
OF ARTICLES THAT ARE COMING OUT
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE WRITING ABOUT
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT ARE BEING
TRIED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THAT I WOULD JUST LIKE TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE ALL VERY WELL
AWARE WHAT'S HAPPENING LOCALLY
WITHOUT COMBINED EFFORT BETWEEN
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
JUST ANOTHER THING I MEAN THE
POINT BUT THERE'S NO
DISAGREEMENT THAT THERE IS
PROBLEMS BUT HOUSING AND
ESPECIALLY WITH OF AFFORDABILITY.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT ALSO WAS
NOT TALKED ABOUT TODAY IS HOW.
ONE OF THE DEFINITIONS OF THE
PROBLEM WE'RE FACING IN ADDITION
TO IT BEING A HOUSING CRISIS IS
THAT THERE HAS BEEN AN AMAZING
SUCCESS BLOOM IN SILICON VALLEY.
AND I KNOW YOU CAN'T SEE WHAT
I'M HOLDING UP HERE BUT THIS
WOULD BE A PICTURE OF THE KIND
OF HOUSING THAT WOULD BE
SURROUNDING.
THE APPLE CAMPUS IF PROVIDING
THE KIND OF HOUSING THAT THEIR
JOBS GROWTH HAS INITIATED AND
WE'VE GOT THESE KIND OF IMAGES
FOR FACEBOOK AND GOOGLE AND
OTHERS ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE HAD THOSE COMPANIES THAT
HAD.
BROWSING SUCCESSES WITH WITH
WHAT THEY'VE DONE.
AND HOW TALENTED BIG BUSINESS IS
IN OFF LOADING VOSE EXPENSES IN
ORDER TO INCREASE THEIR PROFIT
MARGINS SO HI.
IN I UNDERSTAND THERE WAS THE A
GRAND JURY REPORT THAT CAME OUT
OF THE SANTA CLARA CIVIL GRAND
JURY THAT WAS LOOKING AT WHAT
SILICON VALLEY COULD DO IF THEY
WERE COMMITTED TO SOLVING.
THE PROBLEM THAT THEY HAVE HAD
THE BIGGEST AND IN CREATING
SAYING THAT.
DEMI THIS SOUNDS LIKE A HUGE
NUMBER BUT WITH TWENTY OR THIRTY
BILLION DOLLARS THAT THEY WERE
IDENTIFYING IS AVAILABLE.
COMING OUT OF SILICON VALLEY IF
THERE WERE A FAIRER WAY OF
ASSESSING THEM THEY COULD SOLVE
FOR HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
PROBLEM AND THE BUILDING PROBLEM.
FOR TWENTY BILLION FOR THIRTY
BILLION TWENTY BILLION THEY SAY
IF THEY MOVED TO TO GILROY WHICH
WE DON'T KNOW IF KALRA WOULD
LIKE THAT.
THE I HAVE A GREAT CONCERN ABOUT
THE WAY IN WHICH THERE IS TOO
OFTEN A DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE
HARD WORK THAT'S GOING ON AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
AND THE KIND OF TOP DOWN WE'VE
GOT TO DO SOMETHING WE'VE GOT TO
FIX THIS.
SO I ENCOURAGE YOU TO REALLY
KEEP THE DOOR OPEN TO WORKING IN
A COLLABORATIVE WAY WITH THOSE
MORE VOICES LIKE TO LEAVE A
CALIFORNIA CITIES TO SEE HOW WE
MOVE FORWARD. TO HANDLE THIS IN
A WAY THAT IS FAIR AND EQUITABLE
AND HAS A LONG TERM SOLUTION AND
SUPPORT FOR WHAT WE DO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHECK
SPEAKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS BRIAN
WHITE HERE WE HAVE TO THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING ALLIANCE.
WHERE COALITION OF LOVE MARKET
DEVELOPERS SINGLE FAMILY MULTI
FAMILY DEVELOPERS?
AND A LOT OF OUR FOLKS ARE
ACTUALLY SEALS EXECUTIVES.
AND I WANNA GET INVOLVED IN
THESE ISSUES SO THEY'RE VERY
PIECE OF OF THE OF THE HEARING.
WHO JUST CAME UP THE STAIRS OF
HOUSE AND SHE'S AT THE SLIDES
FROM I THINK WAS A DAVID TURNER
FROM UC?
BERKELEY.
HE SAID THAT THE OR THE
INFORMATION FOUND WAS AT ALLOW
THE THE LAND ITSELF THERE'S A
RESULT.
WELL WE ALSO HAVE TO TO KEEP IN
MIND THAT JUST AS ITS OWN.
DOES ME ACTUALLY IT'S BUILT.
AND IS ALSO AN AUTHOR THAT'S NOT
ZONED AS YOU COULD GET BILLED
TWENTY LOOK AT BOTH OF THESE
OPPORTUNITIES A LOT OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE OUT THERE
WITH A FOUR TO WORKING WITH YOU
GUYS -- AND
THIS YEAR AND AND WORKING
FAMILIES ISSUE SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT.
OKAY SEE NONE WILL CLOSE PUBLIC
COMMENT -- I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN TODAY'S HEARING
THE PANELISTS MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC COLLEAGUES.
THIS IS A VERY --
PRODUCTIVE AND HELPFUL HEARING
AND HOPEFULLY CAN HELP FRAME
SOME OF THE ISSUES AS WE MOVE
INTO -- THE
ROLLER COASTER KNOWN AS OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SO.
I THANK YOU EVERYONE AND UP AT
THE